[Music]
welcome to the huberman lab guest Series
where I and an expert guest discuss
science and science-based tools for
everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford School of Medicine
today's episode marks the first in a
four episode series all about Mental
Health
the expert guest for this series is Dr
Paul Conte Dr Paul Conti is a medical
doctor and psychiatrist who completed
his medical training at Stanford
University School of Medicine and then
went on to become chief resident of
Psychiatry at Harvard Medical School he
then went on to found the Pacific
Premier Group which is a collection of
psychiatrists and therapists who are
expert in treating all types of
psychiatric disorders and life stressors
across the four episodes of this series
on Mental Health Dr Conti teaches us
about the structure of our own minds and
how to think about our own minds as a
way to enhance our mental health he
explains how our subconscious mind and
our conscious mind interact to drive our
emotions our decision making and our
behavior and while any series about
mental health requires that from time to
time we discuss personality disorders
and psychiatric challenges the main
discussion in today's episode and in
fact all four episodes in this series
are about what it means to be mentally
healthy and how to build one's mental
health through specific practices either
done alone or with a therapist today's
episode addresses several key questions
as well as provides protocols for you to
address questions about your own mental
health for instance you will learn what
constitutes the most mentally healthy
version of yourself you will learn to
assess and indeed you will learn
protocols for addressing levels of
anxiety levels of your confidence how to
think about your beliefs and internal
narratives how to think about your
self-talk and restructure your self-talk
we discuss common challenges such as
overthinking we talk about the role of
defense mechanisms and other aspects of
the conscious and unconscious mind
interactions that can lead us toward or
away from the healthiest versions of
ourselves you'll notice that during the
first five minutes or so of today's
discussion Dr Conti describes a
framework of what he refers to as the
structure of self and the function of
self and he describes several pillars
for understanding what those are I'd
like to highlight that while that short
portion of our discussion does bring up
a number of terms that are likely to be
novel to you they certainly were novel
to me that as our conversation proceeds
you will really come to appreciate just
how simple and yet powerful that
framework is it will help you understand
for instance the relationship between
your conscious mind and your
subconscious mind in ways that you can
really apply toward enhancing your
mental health in addition to that Dr
Conte has generously provided a few PDFs
which illustrate that framework for you
and that are available completely zero
cost by going to the links in the show
note captions so you have the option to
download those PDFs and to look them
over either prior to or during or
perhaps after you listen to these four
podcast episodes as a final note before
beginning today's discussion
want to emphasize my sentiment which I'm
confident will soon be your sentiment as
well which is that Dr Paul Conti shares
with us immensely powerful tools for
enhancing mental health that at least to
my knowledge have never been shared
publicly before in fact as somebody who
has done more than three decades of
therapy I've never before been exposed
to a conversation about the structure of
the mind and the subconscious mind as
well as tools and protocols for
enhancing mental health as powerful as
these for me the information was
absolutely transformative in terms of
reshaping my thought patterns my
emotional patterns and indeed several of
my behavioral patterns and I'm confident
that the information that you'll glean
from today's episode and throughout the
series will be positively transformative
for you as well before we begin I'd like
to emphasize that this podcast is
separate from my teaching and research
roles at Stanford it is however part of
my desire and effort to bring zero cost
to Consumer information about science
and science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme I'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast
our first sponsor is better help
betterhelp offers Professional Therapy
with a licensed therapist carried out
online I personally have been doing
weekly therapy for more than 30 years
and while that Weekly therapy was
initiated not by my own request it was
in fact a requirement for me to remain
in high school over time I really came
to appreciate just how valuable doing
quality therapy is in fact I look at
doing quality therapy much in the same
way that I look at going to the gym or
doing cardiovascular training such as
running as ways to enhance my physical
health I see therapy as a vital way to
enhance one's mental health the beauty
of better help is that they make it very
easy to find an excellent therapist an
excellent therapist can be defined as
somebody who is going to be very
supportive of you in an objective way
with whom you have excellent rapport
with and who can help you arrive at Key
insights that you wouldn't have
otherwise been able to find and because
better help therapy is conducted
entirely online it's extremely
convenient and easy to incorporate into
the rest of your life so if you're
interested in better help go to
betterhelp.com huberman to get 10 off
your first month that's better help
spelled help.com huberman today's
episode is also brought To Us by waking
up waking up is a meditation app that
offers dozens of guided meditation
sessions mindfulness trainings yoga need
your sessions and more
by now there's an abundance of data
showing that even short daily
meditations can greatly improve our mood
reduce anxiety improve our ability to
focus and can improve our memory and
while there are many different forms of
meditation most people find it difficult
to find and stick to a meditation
practice in a way that is most
beneficial for them the waking up app
makes it extremely easy to learn how to
meditate and to carry out your daily
meditation practice in a way that's
going to be most effective and efficient
for you it includes a variety of
different types of meditations of
different duration as well as things
like Yoga Nidra which place the brain
and body into a sort of pseudo sleep
that allows you to emerge feeling
incredibly mentally refreshed in fact
the science around Yoga Nidra is really
impressive showing that after a Yoga
Nidra session levels of dopamine in
certain areas of the brain are enhanced
by up to 60 percent which places the
brain and body into a state of enhanced
Readiness for mental work and for
physical work another thing I really
like about the waking up app is that it
provides a 30 day day introduction
course so for those of you that have not
meditated before or getting back to a
meditation practice that's fantastic or
if you're somebody who's already a
skilled and regular meditator waking up
has more advanced meditations and yoga
need your sessions for you as well if
you'd like to try the waking up app you
can go to wakingup.com huberman and
access a free 30-day trial again that's
wakingup.com huberman and now for my
discussion about how to understand and
assess your level of mental health with
Dr Paul Conte Dr Paul Conti welcome
thank you I'm very excited for today's
episode and for this series because I
like so many other people out there have
a lot of questions about myself and
themselves and not just about ourselves
but how the different personality types
out there the healthy types the
narcissists the you know all the things
that we hear about these days
gaslighting all these sorts of things
what all of that really is
perhaps we can dispel some of the myths
that exist during the course of this
series I'm sure we will sure you will
and also
raise certain important questions that
we should all ask ourselves in terms of
trying to understand who we are and how
we can be the best versions of ourselves
how we can experience the most happiness
also the the most richness in life
because of course life isn't just all
about being happy so to start off this
question I want to raise a parallel with
something I think for most people is is
more concrete which is physical health
you know
um while there isn't an ideal physical
self that's been defined by the medical
community we know for instance that
there is a range of blood pressures that
are considered healthy there's a range
of body mass index that's considered
healthy although that's a little
controversial because it depends on how
much muscle how lean people are Etc but
you know I think it's reasonable to say
that the healthy individual is not going
to get exhausted walking up a flight of
stairs that they could bend down and
lift an object without hurting
themselves they might even have some
additional strength or endurance Etc
within the physical health domain all of
that is fairly well scripted and there
are protocols that people can follow to
improve their physical health we've
covered many of them on this podcast
before
when it comes to mental health and it
comes to concepts of the self
Things become much more abstract for
people in fact I think most people
including myself are kind of wandering
around in the dark wondering whether or
not we are the best versions of
ourselves whether or not we're thinking
about ourselves and the world around us
in the best ways so to start things off
you tell us
what is the healthy version of self I
mean what what should we all be aspiring
to you've worked with people who uh
presumably are healthy and people who
have severe pathologies of
different psychiatric types right
bipolar narcissistic sociopathic uh and
everything in between
so for me and for the listeners what is
a healthy self what should we be
striving for a healthy self approaches
life through the lens of agency and
gratitude if you look at happy people
you know people who like their lives
right no matter what stage of Life
they're at right no matter what their
socioeconomic status is you know race
religion there's so many things that we
we think matters right and and and they
matter to a lot of things do they matter
to is someone happy or not right they
they are not factors right the factors
that tell us is this person enjoying
life are they going to take care of
themselves are they happy they're here
are they engaged productively in the
world is agency and gratitude and if we
have those two things then it's
interesting you almost never see someone
go wrong right and even if if they're
difficulties even if there are if things
happen in life that that can make some
unhappiness right it doesn't take away
the person's engagement in life the
person's enthusiasm for life and I think
if you look at even traditions of
understanding how are people happy
whether it's in Psychiatry or it's
through literature or through a
religious lens it is always people who
approach life through the lens of agency
and gratitude
could we go a little bit deeper on
agency and gratitude sure when I hear
the words agency and gratitude I think
agency and ability to affect the world
around me in the ways that I want and I
think gratitude being thankful and we
did an entire episode all about
gratitude practices some of the
neuroscience and neuroimaging and
neurochemical changes that occur in the
brain and body when people exert a
gratitude practice but I have a feeling
that when you talk about agency and
gratitude you might be talking about
something slightly or maybe even quite a
bit different than the way that I'm
defining it yeah I would say agency and
gratitude are these amazing rewards
right that sit on top of the highly
complex brain function inside of us and
the highly complex psychology in all of
us so if we think about a self right
that I identify a self right I'm an eye
right if I'm going to approach the world
with agency and gratitude that's sitting
on on top of a lot of healthy things
right and the idea that okay there are
ways in which we can be mentally
unhealthy right but to start with like
what is going on inside of us right and
what does it look like when we're
healthy so there's a structure of the
self right there's function of the self
and if we look at the structure and the
function and the parts the components of
structure and function we can come to
understand okay what is going on in us
what might we change for the better how
do we build empowerment right is it
empowerment is is the the the
ability to navigate the world around us
and to bring myself to bear in ways that
are effective and from empowerment
arises the sense of agency right I have
agency because I am empowered right and
also from a healthy structure of self
and function of self we end up with
humility right we come through that with
a sense of our our place in the world
and our power in the world to to
navigate as we choose but also a sense
of the world around us that's far more
complicated right than just we are
extends Beyond us to other people to the
climate around us to the health of the
whole planet right we we feel a sense of
humility that I'm here and I can do good
things I'm fortunate to be here and I'm
part of this bigger ecosystem right all
the way up to the scale of the ecosystem
of earth right and if we feel that
humility then we approach the world
through the lens of gratitude so the
idea that a healthy structure of self
and a healthy function of self leads to
empowerment and humility and then upon
that we are we are sort of imbued with
agency and gratitude and that leads us
forth to happy lives okay so it's clear
to me why having agency and gratitude
would be wonderful perhaps even the goal
state that we should all be seeking to
achieve
and it also makes sense to me as to why
empowerment and humility are important
components that feed into our ability to
have agency and gratitude yes right
because all of that
at least to my mind sums to in a very
clear statement about having agency and
gratitude is the best way to approach
life that all makes perfect sense to me
and yet I've never really thought about
it that way and I think most people
haven't ever been told this right I mean
what should we be seeking agency and
gratitude yes so we've heard endless
number of podcasts including this
podcast about physical health and we've
been told by physicians and everybody
else that you know we should seek to
have a relatively low blood pressure we
should seek to have a relatively low
heart rate that our cholesterol should
be at a certain level
Etc So within the physical health domain
you know there are strong clear messages
about what we should all be striving
toward and in a similar way to how we're
discussing the self and psychology you
know I don't think anyone seeks to have
low blood pressure or low heart rate
because that's what they want per se
they want those things along with some
capacity for endurance the ability to to
you know lift an object so some strength
Etc because of the way that those
metrics of Health allow them to move
through the world in the best possible
way in other words having some degree of
endurance allows you to walk down the
block maybe a lot further or to walk up
several flights of stairs or to have
some strength allows you to pick up
objects and effectively move through
life right
you're telling us that having a sense of
agency and gratitude
and that agency and gratitude are
undergirded by empowerment and humility
and that's the best way to move through
life the most effective happiest if you
will way to move through life
well then I think we have to ask
ourselves the same thing we would ask
about physical fitness which is what
goes into creating a sense of agency and
gratitude empowerment and humility you
know what are the action steps because
if I want more endurance I know to get
on an exercise bike or or a treadmill or
go out for a run a few times a week or
more if I want to get stronger I'm going
to lift objects that are difficult to
lift until they're easier to lift I mean
so pretty straightforward in the
physical domain but in the in the mental
health domain in the psychological
domain it does become a bit more
abstract I think in part because no
one's ever told us certainly no one's
ever told me what you really need and is
agency and gratitude in order to have
the best possible life so I very much
appreciate that you're telling us this
and I'd love for you to tell us what are
the action steps that go into creating
these things that we're calling agency
gratitude empowerment and humility now
there's actually quite a strong parallel
between the physical health Dimension
and the mental health Dimension so so as
you're saying like why do you put in the
time the energy the learning right to be
physically healthy right it's a lot of
effort and and we put so much of
ourselves towards it if we decide that
we value that right why do we do it
right because as you said it's the best
way to approach life like there may be
something that I want to do I I want to
run a race right or I you know I want to
climb a mountain right but ultimately we
take care of ourselves physically
because we don't know what's coming next
in life and we want to be prepared for
it good bad and otherwise right and the
same thing is true of mental health so I
can feel grateful for something I can
feel grateful that I'm still breathing
right now right I can exercise agency I
can pick up that cup and take a drink
right but that doesn't mean that I'm
living life through the lens of agency
and gratitude which is consistent with
every opinion if you look
psychologically through the lens of
literature through the lens of sociology
and psychology agency and gratitude make
happiness right they're ways of
approaching life and just like physical
health is undergirded by by
cardiovascular health heart health
muscle strength right there's an
undergirding of agency and gratitude and
empowerment and humility are ways of
describing okay what arises right from
understanding ourselves taking care of
ourselves that then gives us the agency
and gratitude so we have empowerment we
have humility but where does it all come
from right so just like we have to
understand the physical body and what to
do to it in order to be healthy right we
also have to understand the mind right
the self that wants to be healthier and
that comes through understanding the
structure of the self and we have enough
science through the lens of neurobiology
and Psychiatry to understand the
structure of self and then the function
of self right how we work right how we
interface with the world so it's
actually not more complicated than
physical health it's just that we don't
spell it out that way right we come at
it through the lens of pathology of
what's wrong and who has some diagnosis
and you know we're looking for the
problematic instead of saying like what
do we look like when we're happy right
and then going and digging down into the
mechanics of it all right and if we're
not in that state right to go and look
at that and to make changes just as if
you were very very physically healthy
right but you know your heart rate
couldn't go up that much without you
feeling very very fatigued we'd say well
look you're doing a lot of the right
things right but let's work more on on
your heart right we would go look at the
specifics of it because that's how we
understand it and we just don't apply
the same science logic common sense to
mental health as we do to physical
health but it's time for that to change
because we have the knowledge and
ability to do just that
when we had Dr Andy Galpin on this
podcast to do a series on physical
health and fitness essentially he said
something that really stuck with me
which was that the number of different
workouts that people can do out there
body weight workouts work with weights
with machines you can run far you can
run shorter distances more quickly you
know you can do planks you know sit-ups
so many variations on exercise routines
but what he very clearly stated was that
there are only a few core adaptations
that the body can undergo that lead to
these byproducts that we call lower
blood pressure enhanced endurance
improves strength improved neuromuscular
function improve brain function for that
matter
it sounds to me like there are a lot of
parallels in creating the healthy
psychological self
so what are the core components that I
and others should think about in terms
of understanding I think you describe
them as the structure of the self and
the functions of the self again just to
draw a parallel if we were talking about
physical health we'd say okay there's
connections between nerves and muscle
that allows us to move our limbs if you
apply a certain amount of resistance you
get a certain adaptation which is the
the neuromuscular connection gets
stronger the muscle might get bigger or
just stronger Etc
flexibility you know you just push your
range of motion just a little bit into
discomfort you do that we it so happens
to be the case that you do that for just
a couple of minutes each day over the
course of about a week or so you get a
significant increase in flexibility okay
so it's all very clear in the physical
domain in the psychological domain I
hear you telling us that the action
steps that we all should be taking in
order to be the happiest version of
ourselves by achieving agency and
gratitude
is to explore the structure of self and
the function of self
so if you could tell us about what is
the structure of self like what goes
into Andrew being Andrew and Paul being
Paul and whoever The Listener is into
being who they are what is that and what
is the function of self how how does a
psychiatrist think about that how should
we think about that okay if I could
start maybe to set the stage for that
right by pointing out that as we go up
the hierarchy right of Health right
everything should get simpler right not
more complicated right if you think
about physical health right there's so
much complexity on the initial levels
right so we think about you know your
physical health status versus mine right
it's going to be different right we're
going to have different cardiac function
and muscle function and pulmonary
function and if we're going to be
healthy we could do a lot of different
things right there might be a whole set
of choices that would work well for you
different choices that would work for me
and we can gauge intensity timing
frequency right it's very complicated
when we're on and the the lower levels
of the hierarchy as we get higher up
let's say you and I both do the right
things right then what happens we both
have endurance right we both have some
strength we're both robust right things
are getting simpler because we're we're
approaching the unique idiosyncrasies in
all of us right and we have to look at
that and look at that in a very specific
way but what we're trying to get to is
is something that's common for all of us
so stamina for example in physical
health and endurance right and agency
and gratitude in mental health right so
then if we go and we look and we look at
the structure of the self and the
function of self we find that there's
more complexity but that it is also
understandable I mean there's tremendous
complexity in the body just as there's
tremendous complexity in the mind and we
can understand what is the structure of
self what is the function of self and we
can look at that and assess that in the
same way we would physical health
parameters so that we arrive at the
place we want to be be it endurance or
agency or gratitude so structure of self
right we all have an unconscious mind
right and we pay so little attention to
this part of us that really is the
biological supercomputer right so
millions of things are going on all the
time like in every Split Second so for
example I can say these words right you
can listen to the words you can say
things back and I can listen right there
are millions and millions of things
going on under the surface much of which
comes from either biological
predispositions right or habits over
time right thought processes patterns
right so this unconscious mind this
super computer is doing all of these
things like you know at the speed of
light right there are electrical and
chemical signals and you know multiple
Pathways as common as complicated as
super highway systems that then get
Consolidated and communicate with others
right and then what comes up from all of
that is the conscious mind so imagine an
iceberg right and it's a really really
big Iceberg right and and we see the
part above the surface right that's the
conscious mind right but there's a huge
part of this Iceberg maybe 95 of it
that's underneath the water right
there's this hulking mass that we don't
see that's the unconscious mind right
and it's feeding up to the conscious
mind which is a much smaller part of our
brain function right but it's the part
that we're aware of right it's sitting
on top of all the unconscious things
which are extremely important but then
we become aware so that we can engage in
the real world in order for us to have
this conversation the millions of things
per second have to be going on
underneath the surface so that you and I
as conscious eyes right as conscious
selves Can Ride Along on top of it so
that's the part of the iceberg that's
above of the water it's the conscious
itself then imagine that the conscious
self is girded by by a a set of
um you know long uh tendrils that come
out from under the water right that
their defense mechanisms that are
unconscious to us that sort of gird the
conscious mind so do we rationalize
automatically do we avoid automatically
do we act out automatically are these
things in Us in ways that we can observe
and change but that are there to try and
protect the conscious mind from the the
slings and arrows of the world around us
right so if you imagine there's the big
part of the iceberg under the water the
unconscious mind the conscious mind is
riding on top of it but the conscious
mind that part sticking out of the water
is vulnerable right so imagine that
there's a defensive structure then that
arises from the part of the iceberg
that's underwater that is there to
defend and protect the conscious mind
So when you say to defend and protect
when you say that the conscious mind is
vulnerable
what do you mean do you mean that it's
vulnerable to physical attack or that
it's vulnerable to us realizing that
we're just a bunch of neurons that are
clicking away underneath like in other
words where does the vulnerability of
the conscious mind really reside
um not physically where does it reside
but you know what am I so worried about
in terms of my safety I mean right now
we're in a room I feel pretty safe
um I don't think you're going to attack
me verbally or physically I suppose it's
possible that could happen but it seems
like a very distant possibility So when
you say that these defenses are there to
protect us from some sort of awareness
what awareness are we trying to avoid so
the the vulnerability of the conscious
mind is to fear confusion despair right
there's so many things that that we can
fear right some people are afraid of
snakes or spiders some people are afraid
of death some people are afraid of
health issues that could come to them or
to people they love we can get confused
and not know what decisions to make and
how to navigate the world and how to be
who we want to be to ourselves and to
others right we can feel tremendously
vulnerable and despairing if we lose
others or you know we start to see
things happening in the world around us
that that we don't like right we start
to feel like what will happen to the
planet we live on whether it be War
where I live will my children be safe
right there's so much that we need to
protect ourselves again so that
vulnerable part of of us right the part
of the iceberg sticking out above the
water needs a defensive structure around
it to protect it against the
vulnerability of fear confusion despair
right and because the conscious mind is
is sticking out of the water with a
defensive structure around it right it
is the the raw material from which we
create our character structure so the
character structure is all of that the
part under the water the part above the
water the defensive structure so imagine
like a nest around all of that and
that's the character structure that we
utilize to interface with the world
right so the character structure is it's
like the thing that I'm using right it's
like if you're driving somewhere in a
car right the car is the thing that
you're using to go there right the
character structure is the thing that
we're using to interface with the world
so for example how trusting am I versus
suspicious right how readily do I come
to make friends with people right how uh
how much do I act out if I'm frustrated
right how much do I
um you know exclaim something negative
right as opposed to holding it inside of
me how much do I rationalize if
something isn't going well do I want to
look at it and maybe see that it is so
that I don't have to face it right how
much do I avoid problems in the world
around me how much do I exercise
altruism right these are all the ways in
which we're engaging with the world
around us and this determines the self
imagine that the self then grows out of
this now Nest from the the character
structure that we use to interface with
the world and the decisions that we make
so if our character structure is is the
thing through which we engage with the
world then we're enacting right what is
inside of us right what we've determined
through our unconscious mind our
conscious mind our defense mechanism
there's a certain us that that comes at
the world in a certain way and if we're
more or less trusting more or less
avoidant we rationalize more or less
these are the factors that determine
like where do our lives go right because
on top of all of this imagine that the
nest of the character structure around
all of this grows from it the self right
the product of the feelings inside the
things that we know about ourselves and
don't know about ourselves the decisions
that all of it leads to so I may choose
to be for example more trusting and that
may bring an opportunity to me that I
wouldn't have otherwise had right I may
choose to be more trusting and and it
may bring risk to me that I wouldn't
otherwise have had so we want to be as
healthy as we can as knowledgeable of
ourselves in the world around us so that
it's safe for us to have a healthy
character structure through which we can
engage in the world around us with a
sense of prudence right taking
reasonable risks right not too little so
that we shut ourselves down and maybe
end up despairing not so much that that
scary things can happen to us and we end
up fearful right but the idea that if we
know ourselves well the character
structure is healthy right because it's
built upon a structure of self and a
function of self that are healthy and
out of it is coming empowerment right
and empowerment and humility right that
then lead us to agency and gratitude
right the idea here is that this is the
character structure that we create that
can then interface with the world in a
way that's good for us and good for the
world around us that leads us to to be
able to live in much more Harmony inside
of ourselves and outside of ourselves
so if I understand correctly defense
mechanisms that grow up out of this
portion of the iceberg that we're
calling the unconscious mind they
protect our conscious self in ways that
can be adaptive or that can be
maladaptive in other words defenses can
be healthier they can be unhealthy yes
and perhaps in a few minutes we can get
into what a healthy versus an unhealthy
defense looks like but the way you
describe character structure sounds to
me like
an array of contextual dispositions I
don't want to add unnecessarily
um complex language but it sounds to me
like a bunch of dispositions like like
if I'm walking into the office where I
know everybody and I see familiar faces
there's no reason for me to be on guard
if I trust those people but if I'm
walking down a street at night that I'm
not familiar with and and I'm starting
to get the sense that you know this
neighborhood might not be the best it
makes sense for me to be on relatively
high alert so different dispositions
depending on different conditions I
can't help but mention my Bulldog
Costello who had basically three
dispositions it was asleep but in all
seriousness the second one was
um kind of bored the Bulldog face is
kind of board or if something was given
to him that he liked or if we were doing
something he liked Delight he basically
had three dispositions as far as I could
tell I think one of the reasons we like
dogs so much or that many of us like
dogs so much is that their decisions are
very predictable take them to the park
he's happy unless you happy to be ill
that day which was rare you know feed
him he's happy right there wasn't a lot
of uh I don't like this particular meal
or I don't like this particular park or
this Bichon frize doesn't smell so good
to me you know there's a it was so
simple and yet people are very complex
right I I can look at myself and say
okay like what is my character structure
or character structure is certain things
I like certain things I dislike certain
things really irritate me
certain environments and people I just
delighted okay so is the definition of a
healthy character structure one in which
the dispositions match the context
perfectly I mean I don't know how any of
us could be like that but is is that
sort of the ideal much in the same way
that
um you know we could probably arrive at
at an ideal
degree of stamina that one could have I
mean some people want run Ultra
marathons you know 100 miles or more
somebody want to run a marathon some
people like me don't really desire to
run a marathon but I want to be able to
run a mile if I need to without being
completely exhausted and injured so you
know when we when we ask ourselves about
character structure
are we asking ourselves about
context-driven dispositions and you know
how do we start to evaluate that for
ourselves I think because we're more
complicated I think it's not
dispositions as much as its
predispositions right so so in the
example that you gave right you have a
certain predisposition to be either
trusting or wary right and and you're
and that's healthy in you right so when
you come into a setting where there's
not a a good reason to feel mistrustful
to feel anxious to feel vulnerable right
then you feel at ease right so you walk
into the work setting they're people you
know they're people you like everything
is okay right you have a different
predisposition when the context is
different right so if the context could
bring a lack of safety then you'll
respond accordingly with the lack of
safety right but but it's possible
certainly those predispositions can be
in unhealthy places right so for example
you might have been traumatized in a
certain way or you might approach the
world in a certain way because a prior
experience that you may not register as
trauma but it may be that within you is
a predisposition to be mistrustful so
you could walk into a room of people
that you know of people who've never met
you any harm and still feel unsafe right
now this happens most often after trauma
but there are other ways people can get
to that where the predisposition isn't
so healthy the converse is true too
right there are people who can have too
much of what's called an omnipotence
defense and then they don't recognize
danger when danger is around them so the
idea the character structure that Nest
right that's built around the defensive
structure and the conscious mind that's
sitting on top of the part of the
iceberg the unconscious mind underwater
right it's that Nest that is interfacing
with the world through a whole set of
predispositions I'd like to take a brief
break and acknowledge one of our
sponsors ag-1 ag-1 is a vitamin mineral
probiotic drink that meets all of your
foundational nutrition needs I started
taking ag-1 way back in 2012. so I'm
delighted that they're sponsoring the
podcast the reason I started taking ag1
and the reason I still take ag1 once or
generally twice per day is that it's the
easiest way for me to ensure that I'm
getting all of the vitamins minerals
probiotics and fiber that I need in my
diet now of course it's essential to get
proper nutrition from Whole Foods but
most people including myself find it
hard to get enough servings of fruits
and vegetables each day and especially
to get enough prebiotics and probiotics
to ensure gut health as you may know
your gut contains trillions of little
microbiota the so-called gut microbiome
which establishes critical connections
with other organs of your body to
enhance brain health as well as to
support your immune system and other
aspects that relate to mental and
physical health one of the most common
questions I get is if you were to take
Just One supplement which supplement
would that be and my answer is always
ag1 because by taking ag1 I'm able to
ensure that I'm getting all of the
vitamins minerals and probiotics that I
need to enhance my mental health
physical health and performance if you'd
like to try ag1 go to drinkag1.com
huberman to claim a special offer
they'll give you five free travel packs
and they'll give you a year's supply of
vitamin D3 K2 again that's drink ag1.com
huberman to claim this special offer I
think most of us are familiar with
assessing and assigning names to the
character structures of others and at
least for most of us we do that with no
professional training or authority right
we say that person is great they're
super nice the person's a jerk they're
like weird you know etc etc
I think very few of us are familiar with
assessing our own character structure
right right and I have to presume that
some of what happens when somebody comes
to you as a psychiatrist or to a
psychologist is that certain questions
are asked and certain narratives are
told that start to reveal to the
clinician the character structure and
perhaps from there some of the possible
defense mechanisms and uh you know
structure of the person's unconscious
mind and conscious mind that obviously
are unaware to them but would be clear
different clinician
much in the same way that if somebody
goes into the doctor and says you know I
don't feel well they can start probing
with questions or are they going to put
you know take a take a re listen to
their breathing right into their heart
right I mean you could help the
stethoscope and figure it out these are
the probes whereas the psychiatrist the
psychologist uses words and language to
probe yes so
what are the sorts of aspects of
character structure that we can be aware
of in ourselves you know I mean in other
words should we be asking what type of
character do I have depending on one
circumstance or another
um should we ask ourselves what sorts of
defenses we have and maybe this would be
a good opportunity to um address this
issue of what are healthy versus
unhealthy defenses because it sounds to
me if I understand correctly that the
defense mechanisms are a very strong
component in determining what our
character structure is right because the
defense mechanisms are unconscious right
the character structure that Nest around
the defenses and the conscious mind
through which we interface with the
world right is very very complicated so
there is many character structures as
there are human beings right so it's
very very complicated but there are
factors that are consistently relevant
across people and get identified as such
so so one example would be isolation
versus affiliation right so does a
person tend to group with others right
or does the person tend to avoid
grouping right and and go about uh
thoughts tasks approaches to life in in
a more a singular manner right so it's
just one element not making value
judgment about it because it can be good
or bad on either end of the spectrum
right so we're just saying what are the
factors so am I more affiliative or do I
tend to isolate and be more singular
that's just one example right another
example could be things like for example
use of humor right does a person use
humor and in what way right does a
person use humor to deflect uh
discomfort in negative situations does a
person use humor in order to belittle
others or to belittle themselves or does
a person not use humor right so these
aspects of character structure and so
much research has been done on this over
the years to determine what is most
Salient right in this this thing that we
use in order to interface with the world
around us out of which grows our self
that makes good sense and and it makes
me want to revise a little bit what I
asked about before which is I said that
when it comes to an exam of physical
health we measure blood pressure measure
um breathing Etc maybe even a blood test
look at some biomarkers but what you're
describing is a little bit more
analogous to The Physician uh addressing
a patient who's having some physical
discomfort or malaise and saying tell me
about your day you know what do you do
when you get up in the morning if the
person says well you know I I drink a
you know a quarter pint of Vodka it's a
very different answer than you know I'd
go outside and get sunlight in my eyes
drink a glass of water and maybe have a
cup of coffee right right you know
um or if somebody says I have six
espresso if I understand correctly the
character structure is better revealed
by
exploring the action States
isolation versus engagement
um as opposed to a read of one specific
biomarker yes um characteristic
structure brought to life
right yes
immediately I'm thinking about movies
and books where we learn so much about
somebody
through observing the way that they
interact with people in in very um very
potent ways so for instance I can think
of countless movies where you learn a
ton about somebody in the first scene
simply because of the way they react to
somebody who you know Cuts them off on
in traffic they just explode okay well
then we think of that person as reactive
from that point on unless there's a
significant amount of material to revise
that but it's in the action of of
getting explosive and cursing Etc as
opposed to if they just kind of laugh it
off or laugh at themselves or blame
someone within their own vehicle or
something like that so is are those the
sorts of things that a clinician like
yourself is listening for when somebody
says you know I don't feel well and you
say well tell me about what's going on
lately and they start describing what's
going on in their life and are you
listening for those places where the the
defense mechanisms can are start start
to reveal themselves the character
structure starts to reveal itself
through these action steps that the
person seems to be taking is that yeah
yeah I mean maybe one way of looking at
character structure is that it's it's
potentialities and positions right that
there's so much that that's latent that
then interfaces with events like a
person stuck in traffic how does that
person respond if that person weren't
stuck in traffic there wouldn't be a
response to it right so so there are
potentialities their predispositions and
then we live through enacting them as
we're moving then through life right and
the the attempts to understand so using
the physical health parallel right if
you came in and you said I don't feel
well right you know we might run a lot
of tests right we might get an MRI or a
CAT scan or even put in the stethoscope
and listening to us inside of you those
we can say are unconscious things like
you know you're not aware of what the
Imaging may show or the blood test may
show or how your lungs may sound when
someone puts a stethoscope on them right
so so a clinician if you're trying to
understand and help someone then you do
want to look for those things right you
want to look for the things that are
underneath the surface but that that can
be very very important right you also
want to look at everything that's on the
surface right so if you're if you're
engaging with someone you're engaging
with the self right the self that grows
out of the character structure Nest
right so by engaging with and and doing
one's best to understand the self then
you learn about what is underneath of it
right so I may then learn well how do
you respond in certain situations right
just like I could ask you questions or
well when do you not feel well right so
you're asking a person questions because
the idea is to understand elements of
the character structure so how do you
respond in certain situations what's
going on inside of you right what do you
understand about yourself and what do
you not understand about yourself right
how do you bring yourself to bear in the
world around you so there's a similar
process going on but here we're trying
to understand the self and the
understanding of the self can help us
understand the components underneath of
the self because that's where we're
going to go to make things better right
the idea is there shouldn't have to be
Miss history or certainly not mystery
any more than there is in physical
health I mean you know rarely someone
comes in and they're really not feeling
well and and a whole set of everything
that should be done is done right Labs
physical examination history Imaging
right and and you still just don't know
right I mean sometimes that can happen
but it's very rare and the same should
apply here that if we're examining a
self right and we're looking for the
components out of which that self comes
right then we should be able to
understand well enough to go back to the
components of self and to make change so
that the self is in a better place right
and and that self can then be empowered
can feel humility right can then come at
life through the altruism and gratitude
that we see because again you show me
someone who's coming at life through
altruism and gratitude and is not happy
with their life and you'll be showing me
something I've never seen before
something entirely new so if we want to
get there we want to know how to get
there and there are ways as there should
be that parallel physical health that
aren't mysterious that we can come at to
make understanding and change
I'm wondering about the role of anxiety
in all of this
the reason I ask about anxiety is that
you said that so much of character
structure is determined by a set of
predispositions and potentialities
and earlier we were talking about
example of either being afraid or
unafraid in particular environments or
feeling like we can walk into a
classroom and learn or whether or not
we're overly concerned about what people
think about us or both right it could be
a mix
whether or not we can Embrace novel
environments in safe and adaptive ways
whether or not we can grow from them
as opposed to whether or not we can be
overtaken by them or perhaps even
injured harm psychologically physically
or both
anxiety to me is is a very basic
function I think about it in terms of
the autonomic nervous system and degrees
of excitability and
Etc and ability to sleep at night and
ability to wake up feeling reasonably
good but not have a panic attack but
anxiety to me does seem like a key node
in all of this meaning
you know most people including myself
I don't walk around thinking about my
character structure I don't walk around
thinking about how I'm going to behave
in a bunch of hypothetical environments
think about the fact that
most mornings I wake up and I feel
pretty good to be quite honest not as
good as I would like to feel and then
absolutely because anything's wrong but
because I think I'm wired to be a little
bit more on the anxious side and to
predict what's going to happen next and
what needs to be done and so until I'm
actually engaging in certain behaviors
that anxiety hums a little bit high for
me the gears turn a little bit faster
perhaps than I would like when I wake up
in the morning but once I engage I feel
like that the speed of that gear turning
matches the demands of Life pretty well
I feel um agency okay
um
so if you don't mind could we explore
this this feeling of anxiety or lack of
anxiety that I think people are pretty
familiar with within themselves at
different times of day and under
different conditions because to me it
seems like it
um an interesting lens to to explore
this notion of character structure and
defenses is anxiety a healthy defense or
an unhealthy defense or does it simply
depend on the circumstances
well we all have some degree of anxiety
in us right we all have some awareness
that like we're navigating the world and
like not everything is is perfect right
this is not Nirvana so there's some
anxiety within us and the thought is
that that anxiety can keep us Vigilant
about the things we should be vigilant
about you know health and safety right
but that too much anxiety Then becomes
counterproductive and we can look at
this in a very regimented way right so
so some anxiety makes sense right it
keeps us being careful it keeps you
because you're being careful as you're
pulling out of a driveway for example
sample right so okay it can be it can be
absolutely fine but let's say you bring
something to clinical attention that
isn't absolutely fine right let's say I
didn't know you and you come in we have
the example that that we that you used
before where where you you walk into
work and there's a group of people that
you that you know well and like right
let's say you told me when I walk in
there I I feel very anxious right I
don't feel like things are okay right so
then we would go through we said that's
not good right maybe it's impacting your
professional life things are not going
well like you really want this to change
because it's impacting your life in a
negative way and we say okay let's look
at that from the perspective of
structure of self right so first
unconscious right is it that just
genetically are you built with just
higher levels of anxiety right so we
could learn okay have you always been
anxious like this is has this always
been in your life since you were a
little kid no matter what so we're
looking for biological nature so to
speak variables we might also look for
things that that have happened to you
that are lodged in your unconscious mind
right is there trauma that you haven't
processed right that now is underneath
the surface but is spinning off more
anxiety right let's say you tell me oh
it wasn't that long ago you started
being anxious ah like did something
happen like did you walk into a group of
people and I don't know you tripped and
you felt bad about something right and
then then you get more anxious right so
are there things going on underneath the
surface that are impacting you like
let's let's look into that right because
that's the biggest part of the iceberg
right then your conscious mind we could
start thinking about okay what what's
going on what are you actively thinking
about right so this is where sometimes
cognitive behavioral techniques can can
come into mind like are you thinking
like oh no I'm scared it isn't going to
go well right like are you having
thoughts or the thoughts and making you
more anxious right what's going on in
your conscious mind right I would also
be very interested in the defenses
around you so for example do you tend to
avoid right has this been getting worse
for three months but but you just your
mind wouldn't acknowledge it right and
by the time you have to acknowledge it
now it's really bad right or do you not
avoid and like this started just started
happening and you want to nip it in the
bud right so I would be interested in
the defense mechanisms right that are
girding your conscious self and I would
be interested in the character structure
what decisions are you then making like
are you going anyway right are you
having trouble so sometimes you avoid
are you then making decisions that make
you late and that causes problems how
does it impact you once you're there are
you engaging differently with people
doing your work differently so I want to
understand the character structure and
ultimately you understand all of this by
probing the self that's riding along on
top of it and then what is the
experience of that self like do you see
that okay this is a problem and I want
to address it but like look I know that
I'm good at what I do and you know I
mean this isn't some like awful thing
about me I just have to deal with it
right or is yourself impacted when you
start thinking maybe I can't do this
anymore I'm not good enough or you know
we want to understand what's the
experience of the self right and if we
do all of that how is it that we don't
get to a place where we can understand
that anxiety right and we can make
things better so just like in physical
health okay maybe we can't but that is a
dramatic outlier if we bring ourselves
to Bear we would say you should not have
to have this in you right because it is
something negative it is making
unhappiness for you it is taking away
from empowerment right and it's also
taking away from humility right because
if someone's beating up on themselves
you're beating up on yourself about it
then that's not humility right then that
that's being sort of falsely persecutory
right this is not an honest humility to
that it leads us away from health so
it's like we don't want it to be this
way right because that is working
against agency and gratitude so we can
understand it and we can go after it and
make it better
one of the most common questions I get
on the internet and I get a lot of
questions is
what can be done to improve confidence
you know and I've thought a lot about
that question and you know what is
confidence in the context of what we're
talking about now is one reasonable
definition of confidence our ability to
trust our predispositions and our
potentialities enough that were we to
encounter scenarios a through z
we feel pretty good that we would
respond the right way in a way that
um wouldn't threaten our conscious mind
at a core level right you know that we
wouldn't
um I used to use the term and joke a lot
in my laboratory uh with the the phrase
you know dissolve into a puddle of our
own tears right it's kind of this like
hyperbolic explanation of of what I
think many people fear like they're
going to be called upon to answer a
question publicly or give a speech or
they're gonna be at a critical moment in
a relationship or something and they're
and just everything is just going to go
so badly wrong that it's just gonna
dissolve them as a person it's
impossible right dissolving a bottle of
our own tears is impossible but I think
that's a fear that a lot of people live
with because we can get into this a
little bit later and we will I'm sure
you know this notion of like protecting
one's ego is it seems really vital to
being a human being some level like we
don't we don't want to dissolve into a
puddle of our own tears so is confidence
the ability to trust ourselves in a
bunch of different contexts
and at the same time I I do have to
raise the this notion of narcissism I
think um uh you know this word gets
thrown around a lot lately but it seems
to me that any
um truly psychologically healthy person
would also not want to be the idiot that
thinks that they're better than they
actually are that's a
um what are your thoughts on this well I
agree with the things that you that you
said about confidence except I would add
two factors that I think are like really
big big factors right right one being
State dependence and the other being
phenomenology right so think about the
state dependence first right when we're
talking about confidence it's it's not
uniform right or it's not automatically
uniform right so if so if you were to
tell me oh I lack confidence right then
I want to understand is that across the
board is like is that a way that you
feel about yourself that like I I'm not
good enough at anything for example
simple right or do you lack confidence
in a specific area right and this is
often the case right and it's a huge
difference right it says that person has
the Machinery of confidence so to speak
right they have the potentialities and
the predispositions for confidence right
when that character structure that's
self-built upon it is in engaging with
the world right but they're not able to
bring it to bear in certain in a certain
special situation so to speak so for
some people for example the way we most
often see this is like the carve out of
romance right where because it's so
emotionally Laden right and like
rejection can feel so bad right that we
can see people who are very confident in
many many aspects of life but they are
very diffident about romance and they'll
say different oh it never works out for
me or no one will ever like me right and
and you see like that's not how that
person actually feels right about
themselves as a whole human being right
which which is then we are coming at how
to make that better in a way that's very
robust right we might say something like
hey here's the good news is you have the
tools and the Machinery that you need
right you're confident in so many ways
right in fact maybe in all ways except
this one so let's go take a look at like
why is that special
right and then and that where are we
we're back to is it something in the
unconscious mind is it is something in
the in the conscious mind about how that
person is engaging right so we we have
to understand what the state is and if
the lack of confidence is State
dependent if the person is not confident
across the board then again we go back
to the same we always go back to the
same places to look right but then you
might more think okay is there an impact
of childhood trauma or early life trauma
that that took away from that person you
know their ability to to gain confidence
right because if you have no confidence
across the board there's a deeper
problem right because there would be
something anyone can be good about and
feel confident in right so the state
dependence is very important as is
phenomenology so what is your experience
of being confident if you tell me
well I'm let's say in a different
version of this example you say you know
actually I'm quite I feel quite
confident when I when I walk into a room
of of people I say okay I want to
understand more about that too right
because if I ask questions about that
and you say well I feel confident
because you know look I'm I'm a pretty
smart person I can think on my feet I
can I can deal well with with people if
something doesn't go right I can recover
from it like I've got you know it's why
I feel confident you know and say okay
that sounds pretty good if you say well
I feel confident because I know that I'm
better than everybody right now we have
a problem right right like that's not
going to go well in other you know in
other uh aspects of life and engagement
like this you know it's not going to
lead to humility and gratitude like so
so where's that coming from and again
maybe there's a deeper problem right as
you say about narcissism right which can
be a a reaction right which is a
reaction to vulnerability right so then
there's was a reaction information and
now the person is actually deeply
diffident right but presents is very
very confident and with a sense of
superiority and that that's not a recipe
for for happiness right so so in the in
approaching it we we do want to
understand all the things that you said
what are the factors and the the set of
predispositions and the set of
potentialities but then what's the real
world experience of that across
situations and what is the person's
experience of that inside which is why
if we're going to understand and help
people like that's the understand part
right you know it's why the conveyor
belt medicine you know it doesn't work
right in situations where we're dealing
with human beings like mental health
right we have to understand something
about people to understand whatever
they're telling us means otherwise you
have no context so you have no knowledge
another very common set of questions
that I get that I believe is very
directly related to this is about
beliefs and internal narratives you know
people ask me all the time
how can I change what I believe about
myself
and they also ask how can I change the
script in my head how do I typically
it's how do I shut down a particular
narrative in my head it seems to fit
very well in thinking about structure of
self because as you pointed out you know
the the self or the structure of self
includes the unconscious mind you know
what's going on below the surface of the
water in this Iceberg model what's going
on in the conscious mind that the
conscious mind is protected by these
defense mechanisms that grow up from the
unconscious mind
from that comes a character structure
and then this thing that we call the
self right right but when it comes to
beliefs and internal narratives those
seem to me things that people are pretty
well aware of in fact the very example
that people are asking me this all the
time how to change beliefs internal
narratives means they are aware of them
it also suggests that
for many people out there their beliefs
about themselves and their internal
narratives are not healthy or at least
they don't feel are serving them well or
that they are intrusive
I don't know how open people are about
their beliefs and internal narratives
when they come to you in the in your
clinical practice but
um if you could tell us a little bit
about beliefs and internal narratives
and uh whether or not they are important
to rewire and and reset
this part is extremely important right
so imagine for example that I'm saying
to myself over and over again that I'm a
loser right or I'm not good enough right
I mean imagine trying to go through life
and someone else we're saying that to
you all the time right I mean it's worse
when it's inside your own head right so
what's going on inside of us our
internal dialogue our internal
narratives are extremely important and
here's where we run into a very big
problem is that we live in an era and in
a culture that is very attuned to Rapid
gratification right and all of this that
we're talking about can change but it
does not change quickly and it's amazing
to me me when you know you'll see under
Insurance paradigms often right no
matter what's going on with someone they
have 10 sessions of cognitive behavioral
treatment right if there's something
like we're trying to change beliefs it's
a guarantee of failure right because
beliefs don't change that fast right so
imagine for example that we you know you
and I chose a word a random word and we
decided to say it 500 times right we'd
each be saying it tonight right it's not
going to be out of our minds by tonight
but because we what took a random word
and said it 500 times right so imagine
that there's something that's highly
emotionally Laden and we've said it
thousands and thousands and thousands of
times right that's not going to go away
quickly right but it can go away and
during the process of it atrophying
right our lives can get better right
this is the opposite of hopeless right
it's actually very very encouraging but
in a world that's rapid gratification
right like how do we fix this how do we
fix this now that doesn't acknowledge
this we hear all the time that a person
has failed therapy right like this is
said all the time that person failed it
what does failed therapy mean right I
mean I think therapy failed that person
right but we we label like oh a person
isn't better right but there are things
going on inside of us that could take
months and months or years to make
better now again that's okay if we're
aware of what's going on just the very
fact that we understand and we're making
change right it helps us feel better
about ourselves and more confident right
that we can change all of this but we
have to approach it in the right way so
let's say that I'm telling myself over
and over again
um you're not going to get there right
and let's say a place I want to go
professionally right or no one's ever
going to really want you right if if I'm
looking for a romantic partner right so
so imagine these things are going on and
they're going on over and over again and
you can imagine now that it's intruded
into the unconscious mind it's going on
in my conscious mind my defensive
structure is Shifting in negative ways
I'm becoming more avoidant like nothing
about this is good and I want it to
change and I wanted to change to
something that says like you can do it
right or you're lovable right or you can
be a good partner to someone so I want
to change it right so imagine now when I
start to make that change I'm blazing a
path right and and I'm blazing a path
where there wasn't a path before right
and I can blaze a path and I can go
through that path but that path is going
to be nothing like maybe the four-lane
highway right adjacent to me where the
thing that I've been telling myself for
years and years and years born of trauma
right is is you know is going back and
forth right I mean it's got a four-lane
highway I'm cutting a path right but
over time you cut that path more and
more you tread that path more and more
you take energy towards that path it
becomes better now let's imagine like
the path is well lit and it's 12 feet
wide and maybe we can pave the path so
more more traffic so to speak goes down
it and we're taking energy away from
that four-lane Highway and maybe it
starts to be overgrown a little bit and
there are cracks in the road like we can
change all of that but we have to
understand what's going on and and
identify it like what is going on inside
of me uh what do I make of it right how
do I understand the process of change
how do I increase my empowerment during
the process of change if we come at it
the right way all of this can be changed
it's not hardwired in us it's just very
very strongly reinforced the same way
our brains are built this way so look we
don't forget our own names right you
know we don't forget where we live you
know back when we were hunting and
Gathering and we don't we don't forget
you know where where the good fruits are
right I mean this goes on in human life
now like we have to remember things it's
very very important if something is has
high emotional balance and we've thought
it a lot that we don't forget it but
that mechanism gets hijacked by things
that are not good for us and we can take
it back but not if we don't understand
what are the tools or the questions that
you uh give or ask of patients in order
to help them along that pathway because
I totally agree that changing beliefs
and internal narratives is very very
hard just one quick example that meshes
with the physical health realm I have a
friend and colleague he's a very
accomplished scientist who is very
overweight for a long period of time he
finally made some behavioral changes
that allowed him to lose I think it was
in upwards of 80 pounds a significant
amount of weight felt much better looked
much better
he just delighted in his ability to do
that but then started to reveal to me
that he was deathly afraid that he was
going to lose control and start eating
the way he was before and stop
exercising in a way that would return
him to his previous weight and feelings
of malaise
and I said well all the things you're
doing are in the direction of Health
none of what you're doing speaks to the
possibility of this all crumbling this
was the dissolve into a puddle of my own
tears kind of narrative but at this
point coming from him
and he just said I know but despite
doing all the right things I'm still
incredibly afraid that it's going to
happen it was as if that the beliefs and
the internal narratives hadn't changed
despite the fact that he was engaging in
the world differently and more
positively uh I haven't checked in with
him recently to find out where he's at
with this now several years later he has
kept off most of the weight not all they
gained a little bit back but he's still
far healthier than than he ever was so
hopefully he's experienced some relief
but you know what do you tell a patient
who is saying you know I've got this
Loop in my head that tells me I'm not
good enough or that even when things are
going well they're going to return to
that state that I fear so much once
again this kind of like you know lack of
agency right just lack of agency lack of
agency lack of empowerment
what what sorts of practical tools can
can one give themselves or that you
would provide to somebody no matter what
is behind what's going on in that
person's mind it's addressable
but you don't know what it is and how to
address it until we ask the question of
what's going on inside right so if he's
afraid that he's going to gain all that
weight back right and he has a history
that if significant negative things
happen he throws self-care to the wind
right then we'd come at it through that
pattern right because he would have a
very you know he'd have a good reason to
be worried right because of this pattern
of something bad happens and I can't I
don't take care of myself for six months
you know maybe someone I'm just making
this up and maybe someone in his life is
ill or he's fearing a death you know and
if it's just something that would say
that's a very legitimate fear to have
like let's let's talk about that like
let's look at where that comes from
right what got that person into that
pattern in the first place right by
understanding the pattern and by working
together right can we can we Stave that
off right but it could be different the
person might say well I'm really I'm
having a lot of food cravings right and
we be like okay what does that mean
where's that coming from or maybe he's
depressed and when and he's getting
depressed and when he's depressed he
can't stop eating more right so you know
you would look or it might just be plain
old fear like this is so good right that
that I'm worried it will go away right
then we might want to reinforce like
okay like you know you're a person who's
able to use circumspection and
perseverance and preserve goodness right
so like you do that and you do that
really well so let's let's make sure
we're doing that here right so you know
a lot of times a person is worried but
that worry is coming through the lens of
Health like they're healthy right so
then we look at okay can we Sue that way
where again where's that coming from
right we can come at it and reinforce
the positive
but if there is something negative
there's a trauma-driven cycle there's
depression there are Cravings we can
understand that too so so I come back to
this idea that there's answers to just
about everything and in a very
regimented scientific way it's not that
hard
to come to them right just like in
Physical Medicine like we have the prime
we have the tools that we need to bring
to bear but you have to understand the
person again if you come in and say I'm
not feeling good and someone else comes
in and says I'm not feeling good the
doctor better not do the same things
right it says how are you not feeling
good okay let me understand that and
then let me map that also to you
whatever underlying state of health you
may have or diagnosis you may have the
same is true in mental health if we just
apply that then it's remarkable the good
that we do which I've seen very
consistently across 20 years of doing
this not only in my own practice but
like who are the people who do really
really well trying to understand and
take care of people including sometimes
not doing too much and realizing like
hey this person is okay like there's a
state of health here but this person is
worried how do we reassure them right
how do we help someone living a good
life live a better life right if we're
going to do all of this we have to
approach people as individuals it's just
I mean the science tells us that and
Common Sense tells us that too but if we
do that that a person can get to the
place they want to be I'd like to
address a different person as an example
a hypothetical person okay and I'm
certain there are many many of these
people out there
these are the sorts of people that think
okay there's a self and a mind and a
unconscious mind Etc but you know at
some level
why not just do what needs to be done in
life like the people that don't want to
explore the self you know because to me
it seems so absolutely clear that just
as it's important to have a certain
level of endurance strength flexibility
so that one can extract the most joy and
agency and gratitude and empowerment and
humility from life
that it makes sense to explore the self
to ask you know where am I internally
strong where am I internally weak you
know where might I perceive myself as
strong where as I'm actually weak right
these seems like these seem like very
important if not crucial questions to
ask but I know that there are certain
number of people in the world think
all of that is just kind of a waste of
time right it's all about doing stuff
it's all you know why explore the self
you know and um I think
the rest of us are looking at that
person often and thinking well you're
exactly the kind of person that needs to
do this because of the ways that you
grate on other people but but not always
right sometimes these people just appear
to be just very effective they're all
about the outward expression of what
they're doing and I certainly don't know
how other people feel waking up in the
morning and going to sleep at night and
throughout the day but to the person
that
feels like introspection and exploring
maybe even Excavating for trauma that
they haven't been in touch with or
haven't dealt with yet but the person
that feels that all of that is
it's kind of not really worth the effort
and that's all about action you know
what can we say to that person or those
people
put differently does one need to change
and need to believe in the power of
these sorts of approaches
in order for them to work uh we often
hear that people don't change until they
want to change and um and could we also
say perhaps that even for the people
that feel like they're functioning
extremely well in all domains of life I
know no such people and I know some very
high achieving people as you do too I
know no such people uh the only people
who seem to exist in that sphere are the
Nars the clear narcissists that to them
just seem like they're doing great but
everyone else can't stand them by the
way narcissists no one else can stand
you
um
what do we say to to those individuals
because I think it's a big swath of
humanity and I think it um it accounts
for a lot of suffering in the world
including their own suffering yeah so I
would make an appeal to common sense
right so imagine you take someone who
doesn't know anything about health they
don't know they don't know how to
exercise don't know how to eat well they
just don't know and they're very really
unhealthy right they're overweight they
have low energy they have sleep apnea
they don't need to have any and and and
you why not just say to them well like
just go be different
like in fact be different now
why aren't you different right now right
like
of course we would never do that because
it's a it's absurd oh and by the way it
also would be cruel right so it's absurd
and it's cruel so we would never do that
right let's say now you let's say we
fast forward some period of months say
make it up right and we see that person
and wow they are much healthier they
have much more energy they've lost
weight they're physically fit
a lot will have gone on in between those
two snapshots of that person that person
has to learn a lot right how does one
take care of oneself right then more
specifically how do I take care of
myself right what healthy foods you know
will I like what healthy foods will I
will I eat how will I put that on the
table what kind of exercises can work
for me how will they work for me how do
I strengthen muscle how do I strengthen
the heart how do I increase lung
capacity right there's learning there's
diligence
um you know there's stick-to-itiveness
right there's resilience that's how the
person gets there right it is no
different and it's mental health right
if we say wow you feel you feel
diffident across the board or you feel
Superior across the board or whatever it
is like life isn't going well and you
don't have things you want and you know
the self-talk is negative and we say
well look what just be different right
now right I mean it's remarkable that
people will say that at times not just
in a way that's
denigrating an awful for others but to
themselves too right I mean I hear
people say this most often to themselves
like why am I not just different right I
want to be different or what's wrong
with me that I'm not and and like yeah
it's like everything else like you have
to apply understanding and work and
effort like the good news is you can get
to whatever change you want I mean a
person can get to whatever reasonable
change
that person wants like you know I'm 54
years old I'm not going to climb Mount
Everest I'm not a mountain climber right
but if I want to like I want to run to
climb some mountains I want to get out
there and do some things I can go do
that right the same thing is true with
our mental health goals but not at the
snap of a finger not by Magic right it's
through applying the same science and
Common Sense a combination of Science
and common sense that we apply to other
things that's why we go through this
procedure of unconscious mind conscious
mind the structure and function of the
self because that's how that's how it's
done that's how the after snapshot looks
different than the before fundamental
Health perspective as well
that's very helpful and I think it's
going to be very helpful to a lot of
people in thinking about what to think
about what sorts of questions should to
address maybe even whether or not to get
therapy and hopefully we'll remap their
Notions of therapy I mean of course this
critically relies on the therapist being
good to excellent
um and I think in the previous
um sit down we had around the uh in the
episode on trauma specifically you
mapped out a number of the features of
quality therapy so we can refer people
to that if they're thinking about it's
time stamped in that episode you know
what to look for in a therapist what how
to assess whether or not it's going well
or not whether or not to move on or or
stay put with that therapist and so on
you've been telling us a lot about the
structure of our of the self
unconscious mind conscious mind defense
mechanisms character structure self
we haven't talked so much about the
function of self I realize it's been
woven in here or there yes
um
could you tell us about the function of
self the functions of self verb actions
I mean are these things that we are all
doing right now that reflect our
character structure
are these things that um we can change
more readily than trying to snap our
fingers and say okay I'm now going to be
a more altruistic person because I can
decide that right now but then
ultimately I have to engage in some
altruistic behaviors
to to lend support to that again same
with the parallel that I can't just snap
my fingers and say lower blood pressure
you know I have to do some meditative
practices some cardiovascular training
and things of that sort uh what what is
this function of self thing what goes
into the functions of self okay so so
just stepping back to the framing right
so there's these two pillars upon which
we build our lives the structure of self
and the function of self and we've been
talking as you said more about the
structure which is more the nouns of it
like there is an unconscious what is in
that unconscious for example there are
defense mechanisms uh uh how are we
using them like it's not all nouns but
it's more what are those things and then
we start talking about how we put them
into practice the function of self is
much more the verbs right so if the
structure is more nouns the function is
more the verbs right the actual
engagement right so so that would start
with an awareness of I so a function of
self has to start with an awareness like
there's a person there isn't there is a
me that is separate from others right
and I have responsibility for this eye
right like it is me no one else is
guiding it like it's me I know there's a
me
okay then on top of that we start seeing
defense mechanisms in action right
because we're thinking about function
right we're aware that there's an eye
but the first thing that starts
happening to that eye are unconscious
things right so the defense mechanisms
because we're not choosing them right
they start doing things automatically so
if for example I have a defense of
avoidance right then I'm not thinking
you know if it's I'd like to meet a new
person but I automatically am shying
away right then that's not it's not good
right it's a factor right but it's a
factor I'm not aware of until I start
this process of introspecting right so
the defense mechanisms are then kind of
determining the lay of the land right so
in that example I'm sorry to interrupt
but it yeah it's starting to interrupt
but in that example
um the the Turning Away you describe as
reflexive so you're talking about
someone perhaps who would like to have a
romantic partner or meet somebody
have a companion and they go to the
grocery store and somebody says
something as they're reaching for the
milk and you know there's that moment of
opportunity where they could say
something back but instead they just
kind of go oh yeah thanks and then they
they kind of move away and then they the
narrative in their head might be oh gosh
that that was silly or but they don't
really think about the the alternate
possibility or there might be no
narrative
they had off to the produce section and
then they go home and and someone says
oh did anything happen if they're good
you mean he went to the grocery store no
right because it's all unconscious right
okay right now again we can can we
explore that and change that yes right
but it's important to understand that
whatever that nest of defense mechanisms
is like that's what I've got right now
right and I'm living through that right
now right that's it's performing a
function right just because it's an
unconscious function does it mean it's
not a very very important function I can
see in that example how it protects the
conscious mind from risk because there's
always the possibility of rejection
there's a possibility of over
interpretation of what the other person
is talking to them for right like is the
person interested in them or whether or
not this is just you know friendly
banter
um the sort that anyone would have next
to anybody that is not special to them
so I can see how the the uh the
unconscious turning away is protective
against all the negative possibilities
and in some sense is pretty rational
because the the probability that that
one interaction could ratchet up to a a
life of companionship and and romance
with somebody is in uh exceedingly small
really although you could imagine a set
of data points where you string together
you know like five second Clips you know
all like the time something like that
has happened right so maybe this is a
person that you know intermittently like
people are interested in them or saying
hey they're saying hello or showing
interest you could string all those
together and the person hasn't noticed
one of them right and then could have a
very negative C nobody no one wants me
no one's interested in me or whatever
the person is saying but but like it's
different if you see from the outside
like it's objectively different but that
person doesn't know and that's why after
being an awareness there is an eye the
next thing that I think of in the in the
function of self is is the defense
mechanisms in action
what are some other examples of defense
mechanisms in action because I think
there's immense interest in this you
know the idea that we have
unconscious processes in us that are
reaching up out of the iceberg and
preventing us from seeing our life and
ourselves the way that it actually is
occurring and perhaps preventing us from
achieving these ideals of agency and
gratitude empowerment and humility you
know I mean these seem like very
powerful and important forces and and I
and I know many other people out there
want to understand whether or not
what we're doing and what we're feeling
and experiencing whether or not that is
serving us well or not so I think the
the place to start is to say that
there's something very very complicated
going on right the the part of the
iceberg underneath the surface right
that biological supercomputer that's
running at a million thoughts and a
million actions and a million internal
processes a second right is constantly
shifting our defensive structure so so
it's complicated and you can almost
imagine that like one leaves and another
comes in and they're shifting and
there's a little bit of one and some of
another like so it's a very complicated
process but we can look at it and
understand so so an example of a defense
mechanism that's very common and can
cause us a lot of problems is projection
right so give two examples of of
projection so so one is the experience
of sitting in a car right and being
stuck in traffic being a little bit late
right and feeling beleaguered right I
mean this has happened to me more times
than I can count but at some point I
started through my own therapy looking
at like what's going on in me right when
I'm doing this right so the thing about
the be feeling beleaguered right as if
what does that mean like there's
something called traffic that exists and
has a mind and wants to thwart me right
is it individual cars is it the people
in the cars right what's going on is
that I'm having a perception of
hostility I feel beleaguered right but
it's it's anger and frustration inside
of me right I'm I'm the one feeling
angry and frustrated there's there's
there's no one and nothing but me that's
feeling anything about this right but I
have this sense of the world around me
being hostile because I'm projecting my
anger outward right now I think this
isn't good because instead of sitting in
traffic and saying look maybe it totally
makes sense that I'm stuck in traffic
and that I'm not happy like maybe I I
should leave a little bit earlier and I
wouldn't be late or if I'm going to work
should I live closer to work I could
make a whole set of decisions that I'm
not making right or maybe I know I
thought it was going to be a 15 minute
drive and like it was an accident right
and okay there are things that I can't
control I'm not supposed to control
everything right if you think about what
can I control being aware of that and
what can I not control right then it can
make the situation much better so this
doesn't happen with this frequency and
it also takes away the anger and the
frustration right so I I think that's a
good example because it it happens a lot
it's very very common but projection
then also happens with people right so
let's say you and I work together and
we're we're going to do something
collaborative together and
I'm just not having a good day and
something negative happened before I
came to work and you know I'm not at my
best and I'm a little bit I'm a little
bit irritable and frustrated right this
happens all the time where then the
person sits down with someone and then
I'm being irritable and frustrated which
doesn't feel good to you right and and
you may become irritable and frustrated
right and then I say oh look he's
irritable and frustrated right but even
if you don't the fact that I feel that
way right that projection often would
lead me to think that it's you who's
that way here I come wanting to do this
job and you're not at your best it's me
who's not at my best right but we do
this all the time and then we make
incorrect or inaccurate attributions
right so so projection is an example of
a defense mechanism that can cause us a
lot of
trouble right a lot of trouble another
can be displacement where if I'm feeling
anger or frustration say in a certain
realm then I the idea of feeling it at
work and then kicking the dog right like
it's not good that we do that we're not
acknowledging what's going on inside of
us at work what we could change what we
could make better and the dog doesn't
want to be kicked right and the dog is
often you know also the family right and
it could be physical or could be through
words right but the idea that with that
there's something negative being
generated in us but but inside we're
we're perceiving that it's coming from
somewhere else right I mean the thought
is all things to lead us astray right
when they're negative defenses right
there can be positive defenses too such
as altruism right that that someone
could do something negative to me right
and instead of me passing that along I
could decide no I'm going to do
something I'm going to do something nice
for the next person I have an
opportunity to do something nice for
right like that's a defense and
sometimes we could think of it and
decide that way but they're people who
react that way like there's something
negative that happens and they respond
with something that's that's different
from that so defense mechanisms can work
against us they can work for us they're
complicated they're combinations of them
but we can look inside and say for
example if I'm using projection all the
time right and I think everyone around
me is kind of always angry and
frustrated right and there's always bad
traffic right but then as we start to
talk about it more it becomes apparent
that there's a lot I'm angry about right
but I'm not aware of it then then
reflection or therapy right or a good
friend we're talking to can help us see
right that hey this is going on inside
of me right and that can really help us
same with use of humor like if I'm using
humor and um I'm kind of decompressing
uncomfortable situations or things that
make me feel uncomfortable maybe that
greases the wheels of social progress
but maybe over time I come to you humor
in a way that's self-denegrating right
well that's not so good anymore but I
may not be aware of the shift just
because I could maybe be funny in
certain situations that I'm now not
using that for myself anymore I'm using
it against myself and by talking to
people by reflection like we can be
aware of the defensive structure that's
going on inside of us and then there's
not an automaticity to it if you point
out that I'm using projection a lot I
can start to be aware of that just like
if someone let's say you were with me at
the grocery store right and someone says
something nice and I shy away and you
say Hey you know you didn't weren't even
aware someone said hello to you and then
I said I want to be more aware of that
like I want I don't want that thing to
happen unconsciously so maybe now I
think okay anytime someone I don't know
says something I'm going to just stop
and think like what's going on here
right is that person being friendly to
me is it is are they just you know it's
just a person exchanging money the cash
rate so like what's going on so we take
what's on unconscious and we make it
conscious so that we can change it
sounds to me like exploring and thinking
about our reflexes is what's really key
here
um
the example of displacement that you
gave you know kicking the dog I couldn't
help but um smile not because I think
it's a good thing to do I never once
kicked my dog by the way folks terrible
thing to do also he was the size of a
boulder it would have injured me more
than would have injured him but I never
would do such a thing however in
Academia there's this
um phenomenon that's very common that
that I refer to as trickle-down anxiety
where the person running the laboratory
is inevitably under a tremendous amount
of stress grants and papers Etc and
graduate students and postdocs will
immediately be familiar with what I'm
describing but
um for those of you that haven't gone to
graduate school
um this will be a little bit foreign but
you'll think of other examples where
when the lab head is under stress
it's incredibly common for lab heads to
walk through the laboratory and start
asking about experiments and telling
people to do additional experiments and
basically just assigning busy work to
people or pressuring what simply cannot
be moved along any faster and when I was
a graduate student I worked for somebody
who was the exact opposite of this
phenotype when I was a postdoc frankly I
worked with someone who's a little bit
of that phenotype um although I still
liked working for him very much but I
used to have a response that at least
for me was adaptive which was I would
always say I'm working as fast as I
carefully can because no scientist ever
wants somebody to cut Corners no good
scientist anyway
um But trickle-down anxiety is common in
every occupation I think we see this
sort of displacement all the time where
someone's anxious and so they go start
creating anxiety for other people I mean
you can just as you're describing I was
just seeing how pathologic that is for
everybody involved so the the academic
the trickle-down anxiety that you were
just talking about is it's a related but
but it's a different defense mechanism
and it's projective identification right
which is which is causing others to feel
the way that you feel in order to get
your needs met is this a form of
projection and actually perhaps you
could um clarify the definition of
projection versus displacement versus
projective identification okay so
projection is when you don't own it so
so it's not me who's mad it's you right
so I don't own that I'm mad at all right
I just think that it's you even though
I'm the one who's mad right displacement
is what comes out of us or what we're
our attribution can shift right it's
it's not this person who's making me
angry it's that person because that's a
safer person right to to be angry at
right or if I'm then going to take out
my anger right instead of metaphorically
kicking a person who might who might
respond to me in a way I don't want
maybe I kick the dog that's helpless to
respond back right that's displacement
projective identification is there's
there's an expression of an emotional
state inside of a person that then
becomes contagious to other people even
though the person isn't trying to do
that the person says I'm going to make
you anxious that's not a defense
mechanism anymore right so here's an
example I think I think this is the best
exam sample of projective identification
so for a little bit of time at work I
would occasionally lose my keys right so
now I'm trying to go and I can't find my
keys right so they say oh I don't know
where my keys are right so I start
expressing something right and I'm
anxious and I'm tense right now people
around me hear that right and what do
they start feeling they start feeling
anxious and tense the way that I do
right and now they're like well now they
want to now they want to find my keys
right they want to help me so that I
stop spreading anxiety and tension into
the whole environment around me right so
then they help me find my keys I say
thank you my own emotional state comes
down and upon reflection I think look I
don't want to do that right I got my I'm
getting my needs met
by making other people feel in a way
that's like not a good or comfortable
way to feel so here's a way around that
like put my keys in the same place every
day right so then I can avoid that
because it doesn't feel good to me like
then if I get out to my car like I find
you know I'm a little bit I'm breathing
a little heavy like I don't doesn't feel
good because I was just agitated right
and I did that to other people too right
so it's an example of how projective
identification works and it's kind of a
simple example but it shows it's
happening all the time you know all
these things are happening all the time
but we can become aware of it then I
don't lose my keys I don't have to feel
bad about I don't have to activate
myself for no reason and I don't have to
activate other people for no reason so
so thinking and reflecting like change
that thing for the better and it can do
it with much bigger things too thank you
for those clarifications
I'd like to touch on humor for a moment
obviously humor is a wonderful thing or
can be a wonderful thing
I've also seen a lot of examples of
where very smart and or accomplished
people because those are not always
um uh the same thing
use sarcasm
as a form of humor and it can be very
funny but I have to imagine based on
everything I'm hearing from you today
that there's a form of sarcasm which is
an unhealthy defense I'm thinking of the
person that no matter what someone else
says that's positive or or no matter
what someone does that could be viewed
as positive they find some way to
diminish it by like through sarcastic
humor right I I see this a lot and I
think closely nested with sarcasm is
cynicism
in fact I have a family member I won't
name who they are to protect the not so
innocent who used to be very cynical
um and I want to ask you what is the
thing about cynicism and they said well
I have had a particular genre of of
schooling growing up a formal schooling
where if anyone behaved um too happy
expressed too much happiness rather
too much delight they were viewed as
stupid like as if to be happy is to um
to be unaware of of the sophistication
and the importance of things in life
right
um and I hope that this is unrelatable
to most people listening but
um I do think that sarcasm is is a
double-edged blade in this sense and
that cynicism is is perhaps um a
double-edged blade as well but that it
might even be worse than sarcasm because
it's a way of really reflecting back
what's
by definition what's not good about life
what's not good about what's happening
and and it does seem protective right it
protects one from disappointment if
you're already disappointed how could
you be further disappointed it's also
seems to me like a bit of a power move
it's like you're gonna be happy well I'm
gonna take that away forever from
everybody like as something that's like
for myself I mean
um does any of this actually hold in the
inside of the clinical literature
um because again I enjoy a good
sarcastic joke yeah in fact there's a
collaboration around a sarcastic joke it
can be truly funny to everybody but
um sarcasm and cynicism
um I feel like are often used to cut
down what would otherwise be
um benevolence or or bonding experiences
absolutely like I grew up in central New
Jersey humor is a weapon right or it
certainly can be right and people can be
very aggressive through humor so so
acting out which is just letting our
aggression flow right that's a defense
right so just being aggressive and
pushing someone back right however that
means like if I don't feel good about
myself I want you to feel not so good
about yourself right is where we start
getting into into Envy right and humor
can be used that way so so that that
sort of biting sarcastic humor is a form
of acting out it's a form of aggression
right it's not humor as a healthy
defense right we can call it the same
thing but we could also call it
different things it's just a Nuance of
our language right if if humor can be a
defense like I trip and fall I make a
little joke people are laughing at with
me instead of at me right hey humor is a
good defense I made myself feel better
made things flow flow more easily but if
I'm using sarcastic humor to assail
someone right then that's not it's not
that thing anymore right you know now
it's a manifestation of aggression right
and the idea that cynicism you know is
is more then we're talking about a world
view right like sarcasm is something
that can be done now like we can make a
sarcastic joke funny or not then it's
over right
um but cynicism is is a way of coming at
the world there's a different kind of
Defense right the idea that hey it's
like the fox and the sour grapes like I
don't I I don't think there's anything
good to be had anyway right so you can't
take anything away from me can't make me
feel worse right I already feel uh very
very bad about the world and about
everybody in it and I'm protecting
myself that way like that's then an
unhealthy defense because what does that
lead to at least isolation at least to
mistrust you know we we know that people
are happy if they live through altruism
and gratitude and they're well connected
with others so so the cynical point of
view which again to some degree being in
the world builds some sentence in us
right like that that's okay that's part
of that's a part of awareness in some
sense but I think what you're talking
about is a very pervasive cynicism that
then is an unhealthy defense that is
very harmful to others like the idea
that I feel lousy about everything and
if you don't I'm going to try and bring
you down right like too much happiness
we'll label that as something right we
could label it as stupid right so now
it's like it's not okay to be happier
than some sort of cynical Baseline right
and again there's nothing about altruism
and gratitude like that's not happy
right I mean who's happy in that
situation cynical the people who are
overly cynical are not happy and the
people around them are not happy
nobody's happy
thanks for the clarification on New
Jersey a good portion of my biological
family is from New Jersey come out
well-armed I I adore them but it's true
there was once a moment at a family
gathering where somebody said uh let's
um let's hug or something and the
reaction was like oh we're gonna hug now
you know it was like it was it was it
was entirely sarcastic and cynical and
like in the the hug that resulted from
that was this like little like like
distant past kind of thing it was and
now I'm laughing about it it's funny and
and they're very loving people but
you're right it's a it's a different
style of humor and discourse yeah so
you've been talking about these two
pillars of the self and who we are and
how things play out in the world for us
as the structure itself and the function
of self and in terms of the function
itself you described self-awareness this
notion or this realization that there is
an eye there's a me
and then we've been talking about
defense mechanisms in action how these
play out in the real world both positive
and negative
it seems to me that a lot of what is
happening here in terms of understanding
the function of self has to do with like
what we pay attention to and like where
we place our our efforts or choose to
not place our attention and not place
our efforts do I have that right right
yeah salience is a is a huge concept and
I think in human existence right I mean
there are thousands upon thousands of
things that that you or I could be
paying attention to right now right but
but we're not paying attention to
anything except what we're doing right
here so we are gating out so many other
thoughts ideas narratives inside now if
something were to shift very quickly if
we heard a loud noise right our
attention would shift right so so our
attention is it's focused we're Salient
to one another because this is what
we've Chosen and we're focusing our
minds and we are also somewhere inside
of us aware that we could shift away
from it is something more important like
something dangerous like were to happen
right so it lets us be here and be
sailing it to one another and have this
conversation right but in the course of
Life what's Salient to us is so
complicated and determined by so many
factors that is absolutely worth a lot
of attention to so so one example is so
many people have a negative internal
dialogue that's running in them over and
over again or they're running through
images events you know they may be
traumatic events or things that they're
not happy with images of themselves in
negative ways
um that these internal narratives or
internal images can become so strong
that there's no room for anything else
so you know an example would be a a
person who who really really loved music
right and could have you know just in
addition to enjoying music like had like
good thoughts while listening to music
like you know what I could go do this
right and and at a history of of like
that really working out well like
following is interests and and like
really creating sort of goodness in his
life right who now was going for long
drives like longer than would be needed
to go somewhere get something like why
the extra time in the car and I had had
a presumption okay a person's listening
to music and thinking but but it didn't
quite add up and then I learned that the
person is not listening to music right
they're using that time so that the
internal narrative right which was a
very very negative repeated internal
negative you're not going to get
anywhere you're not going to make
anything other of yourself right it
could be there in his mind right so it
was a form of self-punishment it was a
form of of taking the anger and
frustration inside and enacting it
towards himself and that was so Salient
that this person could not see his way
to any goodness like nothing could
change nothing could get any better like
felt very sure and very resolved about
that and the answer was yeah that's
right but I nothing can get any better
with this constant Mantra running over
and over again but things can get better
right if that becomes less Salient over
time and your own thoughts and
Reflections become more Salient so at
the other end of that shift you know
that narrative that was still there but
it was weakened right because it takes
time to really change things it was very
much weakened the person was listening
to music again those thoughts had kind
of come back to the surface and they
were being sort of jumbled you know in
ways that that brought new and
interesting thoughts coming from them
and the person was in an entirely
different place and like completely
changed their life right I mean this is
it's this is true right it's a dramatic
example but dramatic examples inform us
right where the salience shifted and
then the life shifted after that
what you're describing in terms of the
specific example
um doesn't resonate with me in terms of
my own experience although as you point
out it's very striking it's very
dramatic
um but it resonates with me from a
different perspective
um I'm not seeking a free clinical
session here but uh but to give meat to
the example I'm about to ask you for
insight on
you know I've never allowed myself to
stay in a bad professional situation for
very long you know when things didn't
feel right or when I sensed someone I
was working with or for wasn't the right
situation I got out despite if I were to
really think about it that could have
been pretty severe long-term
consequences
fortunately it all worked out in fact so
much so that I would say
um you know I pay attention to whether
or not people I work with and four are
of the sort that I want to be working
with and if I sense a particular type of
danger I'll look at that and I I'm 100
so far uh knock on wood but 100 so far
on recognizing later that it was a great
decision to move on and on the flip side
of it I've made I believe excellent
decisions in terms of who to work with
in terms of my podcasting in terms of my
academic career Etc but I've had to move
away from people that just weren't right
for me I don't think they were truly Bad
actors but thank goodness I moved away
and thank goodness I found these other
wonderful people to work with
however there are circumstances that
have been repetitive in my life where
I've
just be honest repeatedly made not good
decisions about who to be involved with
over fairly long periods of time and
there can even be an awareness or I
should say there has been an awareness
like this isn't a good situation and yet
I'm persisting in in seeking out this
and similar types of situations
so I consider myself a at least
partially rational human being with some
degree of introspection
you know when I look at this and I think
okay this is a choice to focus on
placing myself in I have to assume it
placing myself into situations that are
challenging for me
in a way that I know is preventing me
from living in certain ways that I want
and from being happy in certain ways
that I want when you hear a scenario
like that like I can do it over here but
I can't seem to do it over here in fact
I see myself doing it the wrong way here
right a little bit different than the
example you gave a moment ago because
the guy was driving to work not
listening to music but it wasn't putting
two and two together about what was
going on but when somebody can see
what's going on I think this might even
be called the repetition compulsion or
sometimes yeah sometimes yeah what is
that about are people trying to work out
something specific or are they
deliberately creating some friction to
accomplish something else right I mean I
realize this could be infinitely complex
and again I'm not trying to extract um
uh uh the clinical insight for for my
own sake I started that clock on that
thank you
um but I think a lot of people do this
they do what they know they shouldn't be
doing
they know they shouldn't be doing it duh
I just said that two ways and but they
do it like it must serve them in some
way you know you think about
um when you get a dog and you talk to a
dog trainer they say you know dogs do
what works
right they get a reward for doing
something they're going to continue
doing it uh you apply that to the same
sort of thing I'm describing for myself
and that I've observed in other people
and you must say it must work for them
you hear this in kind of pop psychology
like it must work for them like you must
be solving something
why the hell do I do this why do people
do this is it real pathology or is it a
roundabout way to get to something else
that's actually pretty adaptive I mean
instead of defining it as pathology I
would not Define it as pathology I would
Define it as humanness if humanness is
not in and of itself pathological then
all you're doing there is is describing
something that is common widespread
across human beings now it doesn't mean
we can't understand it and make it
healthier right I work in a discipline
that wants to put a number on everything
right label it as something and then do
something about it that's more often
than not ineffective right because we're
not looking at things in a top-down way
of what is Human Experience what are the
natural aspects of human experience that
are less than ideal right that we can
then understand and make better if we
come at it that way then we see ah this
is a great example because here's where
structure meets function right so on the
structure side we said okay there's
defense mechanism we imagine the
branches right that are coming up from
the unconscious mind right and here it
meets function right defense mechanisms
in action on the function side then
determining salience so what I would
imagine in your example my image is that
your defensive structure when you're
doing the thing that's effective right
the professional decisions right it
looks elegant right like there's Harmony
to where those branches are the
Consciousness is sitting in between it
you can see you can see the Elegance to
it right that I can just imagine
shifting right when when you're not
doing the thing effectively right
because now you're using an entirely
different defensive structure which is
going to function differently and create
different salience and I imagine that
it's convoluted and you know that it's
sort of piecemeal that it's not
something elegant right so you say okay
what does that actually mean let's
translate it into what are the actual
defenses so let's think about what
you're not doing when you're making good
decisions in the professional realm
right you are not using denial or
avoidance or rationalization or
projection or projective identification
or acting out right there are all these
things that you are not doing that are
the sort of unhealthy defenses beckoning
to us like oh wouldn't it be easier to
Kick the Can down the road right you
know wouldn't it be easier to just like
no no everything's okay everything's
going to work out okay wouldn't it be
easier instead of being angry at one
person who is really intrinsic to the
environment if you you know it's
actually somebody else you know are you
displacing it projecting that's how
people that's what we get ourselves into
trouble right and if that's going on
then that set of defense mechanisms in
action
right creates something that obscures
the ability to make good judgment right
but with none of those things going on
then what are you doing what you're
applying your intelligence you're
applying your discernment right you're
applying your desire to make things
better you're able to look at it you're
able to bring diligence perseverance
right you're able to bring healthy
aspects of self to the question and
decide like oh I don't want this and it
should be different right and there
again what's going on there's a
complexity under the surface but now
we're coming up towards Simplicity right
we're coming up towards the things that
are healthier that are simplistic if we
look then okay what's going on if you're
making the same mistakes over and over
again well we could you know we would
dive under the hood and really look and
say okay what are you doing there but it
has to be an array of unhealthy defenses
there's no other thing it could be so we
would say okay are you using a are you
using avoidance maybe a little maybe a
lot what about denial what about
rationalization what about projection
like you know you go through the
unhealthy defenses and and you see what
is it that you're bringing to bear that
is leading you astray and then and then
of course the goal is to use the the
role modeling and you role model for
yourself how to be healthy right so
let's take that role modeling and apply
it to the thing you're sort of carving
out and and treating differently and
that's the reason when people talk about
repetition compulsions you know that's
it's not a formal term because
because what we're really talking about
is repetition right and we're interested
like why why do we repeat things now
that's one that's one reason right
because we bring an unhealthy set of
defenses and then at the end of the day
things come out the same because we're
bringing an unhealthy set of defenses
right there can be other motivations
that are related to all of that and
there's again this complexity to it but
but the compulsion part can be that we
can re-enter situations that didn't go
well with the idea that we're gonna
we're gonna fix what happened in the
past we're going to make ourselves feel
better we're going to take away the mark
of trauma because remember trauma
doesn't care about the clock or the
calendar so that's why you'll see
someone who has had say five abusive
relationships that looked very much the
same right and is about to enter the
sixth right and he said it's not because
hopefully in most cases not because that
person like wants to be hurt right I
mean sometimes it's a different problem
right but but there can be a drive
inside of us to try and fix something if
I can make it work this time I won't
have to feel so bad about the other five
right so an attempt to change the past
through one's current actions
right which is rooted in the limbic
system and how and how trauma affects us
and how again it's outside the clock in
the calendar so that kind of magic so to
speak can happen so the brain can seek
that magic but again their unhealthy
defenses coming into play right there
has to be denial right otherwise the
person would map you know if the same
thing happened five times and this looks
the same it's probably going to happen
now right so so anytime you think a a
person most often it's us right you know
is smart enough or worldly enough to
like know better which it happens all
the time right then look for the answer
right you say well shouldn't that person
know better than to get into the six
abusive relationship the answer is like
yes right like because it's not that
hard if you saw a set of circumstances
five times to map that the six is going
to have the same outcome right the
person would do that in other scenarios
right so then you say right that is true
so now let's look for why the person it
doesn't recognize that and again we go
down into the structure of self and the
function of self defense mechanisms in
actions salience the things that we're
talking about now does that fit yeah it
makes sense and what what comes to mind
is the idea of I'm getting into a car
that you know is going to get into an
accident
over and over and over again but being
quite cognizant of safety and its
importance in every other domain of Life
yes not even jaywalking right but
getting into like if certain Ubers
arrived with a little flashing light
that said this ride is going to have an
accident it's like getting getting into
that vehicle and I see this in others as
well yes and it raises all sorts of
questions like
um is the person actually uh
unconsciously afraid of the vehicle
arriving where they want to go because
then
um like are people actually afraid of
things working out
um I mean this gets to something that uh
I'm so sorry can I can I say yeah that's
why you have to know the person right
like who is that person right why do
they not want to get in that car right
are they afraid they're not going to get
somewhere are they afraid they're going
to get somewhere right but ultimately
we're looking for unhealthy defenses and
I I so want to emphasize that that you
know I will often think that the aspect
of my education that's most most helpful
in me doing my job when I'm when I'm in
the job as a practicing psychiatrist is
is actually my mathematics minor right
because there's a lot more math to this
right people tend to think oh mental
health it's all it's all esoteric and
you can sort of say anything you know
anything you you want and there's no way
of proving or disciplinary it's it's not
like that at all right there's a
mathematical aspect to it so if you do
the correct logical Common Sense thing
right in all aspects of your life except
one and you're like
100 times more intelligent than you need
to be to figure it all out right then
then if there's a carve out we say look
that's of huge interest right I mean the
probability that we're going to find
something interesting there's a hundred
percent right because we know that you
know better we know that you do better
but but why here so like that's so
interesting right like that's where the
x marks the spot like let's go dig there
right so then when we go and dig there
like we're gonna find something right
and and we'll see like what is that like
do we find that like oh it's an array of
really unhealthy defense mechanisms
maybe we find that do we find that
there's a deep unconscious motivation
right like we might find that too right
there we might find a lot of things
right but we're going to find them if we
go back to what is the structure of self
what is the function of self if we go
and look like that x marks the spot
means there's Pay Dirt there right and
then when we figure that out then we go
through and we can make things change so
if it's a deep sea needed trauma-driven
unconscious motivation that is resulting
in an unhealthy array of defense
mechanisms well let's go look at that
right let's look at the trauma let's
take the thing that's unconscious and
and bring it to Consciousness right then
we can make that better and that array
of unhealthy defenses again we're not
going to change it overnight but can we
change it very very significantly pretty
rapidly probably yes and we can almost
entirely change it across time so
there's a mathematical aspect of this
that I think is so important to point
out because you know mental health if
this even as a field right just meant we
all want to be mentally healthy like
there's a rhyme and reason to it that
yes it follows science and yes it also
follows common sense and if we apply
those things we get to answers
it's very reassuring
thank you
thinking about the functions of self and
again just to remind myself and and
other people it starts with
self-awareness involves defense
mechanisms in action then there's the
salience
peace but paying attention to what's
inside of us as well as what's external
and then you're now describing a lot of
your choices choice making and behavior
and action in the world
I have to assume that for for the person
trying to improve themselves and get to
agency and gratitude uh that paying
attention to all of these is is
important but of course if a defense
mechanism is unconscious we can't simply
decide okay I'm gonna see the
unconscious defense mechanism does that
mean that we should ask ourselves about
what is most Salient to us
um or should we be focusing on our
behavioral choices I mean in the example
I just gave I'm aware of my behavioral
choices making certain decisions to
engage with certain people and and not
with others
uh
but should I be asking for instance you
know what saline like like what are the
thoughts leading up to that decision
um in other words how does salience of
internal and external uh cues and
processes
um relate to behavior and which of these
should we be paying attention to if our
goal is to eventually change our
Behavior
so so if you think about what we're
starting right we're sort of starting at
the bottom right so we're starting with
okay there is an I right and that's just
not just an apprehension right there's a
lot to that right so so for example I
know someone who who is doing some
mirror meditation staring into the
mirror right looking back itself within
it with a desire to be aware like there
is a me like this me is in the world
right this is the first I've ever heard
of such a practice
um except when I was in elementary
school or maybe it was the ninth grade I
had a teacher who talked about gave us
an assignment to look in the mirror and
ask ourselves questions but if I
understand correctly you think there's
utility to people spending a few minutes
or more looking in the mirror and
thinking about oneself in the eye as a
way to build up this self-awareness do I
have that right if you want to take the
best care of yourself that you can right
you want to understand yourself the best
you can you want to make your life the
best it can be right then if they're
answers right and let's say the answers
are in five or ten different cupboards
right look in all all of them right I
mean that's that's the idea right that
if if we want to know something look
everywhere for it and also realize what
we are building right what we are
creating maybe a recipe there may be
things from different cupboards that
overlap so the way to translate that
practically is to say to find the
answers to what what is either ailing us
why we're repeating things we don't want
to repeat or even if things are going
okay but we want them to be going better
because we don't quite feel the peace
and contentment we want to feel then
look everywhere so in this the function
of cells and the function of self start
with the I right there are ways of
increasing self-awareness you know they
can range from contemplation of self to
meditation to looking in the mirror
right there are things that we can do to
more strongly emphasize to ourselves
that there is an eye and this eye is
going through life right then we know
that there are defense mechanisms and
that they're present that they're acting
in us right we can't just see that them
because they're unconscious but if we
start thinking about them we can learn
about them right and that's where
salience comes into play salience kind
of points both ways right sailings can
point us towards the unconscious mind
right oh I I realize I'm doing this over
and over again or I'm saying this thing
to myself over and over again where is
that coming from we start becoming
curious about ourselves and we look to
the unconscious mind and then we also
look to the conscious mind that's why
after salience is behavior like what am
I doing right and a lot of times we
don't know just examples of we don't
know why we're doing things right
someone who wants to lose weight but
always goes to the grocery store and
comes home and he's like has some sense
of surprise that there are things there
that they don't want to eat right like
why am I behaving in a certain way why
do certain things bother me when other
things don't right why am I really
touchy about one thing and not another
why might there be things that bother
others and not me or vice versa right so
so you know we're looking at what's
going on inside of us us and then how we
respond right because how what may be
upsetting me or what's going on inside
of me both conscious and unconscious
right is then determining how I'm acting
how I'm behaving in the world around me
if I want a better job but I never take
an interview for another job I'm not
going to get another job if I want a
romantic partner but I automatically
turn away from anyone who Smiles at me
I'm not going to have a romantic partner
right if I want life to be better and
there's a certain thing I repeat and I
don't want to repeat that I want to
understand myself better so I can change
the behavior and that's why the the the
function of self ends with strivings
right the stripings are into the future
I know there is an eye I know there's a
network and web of defense mechanisms in
action I know that there's salience
going on inside of me and I'm only going
to pay attention to a few things from
the thousands I could pay attention to I
want to be aware of that and have more
control over that then I'm enacting
behaviors I'm engaging in the world
around me and ultimately I want things
right I want life to be better I want to
have that feeling that you can get to I
want to be in the state of of agency and
gratitude so again these two pillars
structure of self function of self
that's where all the answers are so
there are all the cupboards right there
are these five covers in the structure
of self and five in the function of self
and I know there'll be a you know we'll
have it out there in a PDF right because
you can go back there and that's where
the vast majority of answers are to both
understanding and routes to change
what you just described is incredibly
helpful it's absolutely apparent to me
why looking at all the cupboards is so
key it's also apparent that
um many different aspects of psychology
and Psychiatry
um at least as I understand them might
probe for instance just at the level of
behavior you know I think this is the
the just do it Mantra well just do the
right thing right you know you you're
not finding a romantic partner like you
know schedule three dinners with friends
and ask them to invite over people who
are looking for part it sounds really
simple right but
um much as with the example of my friend
who lost all this weight through
behavioral change that the fear still
lives within them very very strongly and
so clearly there's some some stuff
happening underneath there now
fortunately he did lose the weight and
he's kept most of it off but it's clear
to me that until he addresses some of
these other issues of salience and uh
defense mechanism self-awareness Etc
that
um the fear he's still experiencing
makes total sense because the foundation
of that change is not near really as
strong as it could be maybe right or
maybe it doesn't have to have the fear
but he's not going to learn either one
without the exploration
so he won't if there is risk he won't be
able to avert the risk and if there's
not risk he's then sort of laboring
through life which is difficult enough
without being worried about something
you don't have to be worried about right
so the process of inquiry will always
make that better it's clear to me that
his fear of regaining weight is
absolutely sapping his enjoyment and his
productivity in other domains of life so
Warren's attention right because because
we're deciding in that sort of
mathematical way like it doesn't have to
be that way it doesn't mean it can
change overnight but it can be
understood and it can be changed
well it's for that reason and many other
reasons that I'm very grateful that you
explain these two pillars structure of
self and function of self and how these
flow up to empowerment and humility and
how those flow up to agency and
gratitude you've given us a a set of
ideals and a road map of how to get
there and one that we're going to
continue with in a moment here
um I did want to reiterate what you said
which is that there is a pdf version of
this the structure or this road map of
ideals and how to get there
um that's been provided as a link in the
show note captions
um so people can refer to them there in
visual form if they like if you're
interested in understanding yourself and
in having goodness in your life as much
as you possibly can then you're
interested in the structure of the mind
and this means that you're interested in
the unconscious mind in all the things
that go on a million things a second
that we don't know or understand one by
one but that we can explore and
understand better in total we're also
interested in the conscious mind in
being self-aware or interested in the
array of defense mechanisms and whether
or not they they're elegant and light
passes clearly through them or whether
they're distorting light and creating
misperception if you're interested in
the structure of the mind then you're
also interested in the character
structure right like what is your
character structure what is the nest
around all of it how do you interface
with the world and then you're
interested in the self that you grow
from that phenomenologically meaning
what is your experience of self how does
it feel to you these are all important
parts of this pillar of health and
happiness the other pillar is the
function of the mind and of course
there's overlap there are different
covers but the cupboards all contain
different ingredients that together make
the recipe right so if we're interested
in the function of the mind then we want
to pay attention that there's an eye
like we want to be self-aware and we
want to cultivate self-awareness we're
also interested in how those defense
Mech mechanisms work when they're in
action right what's Salient inside of us
and outside of us what are we paying
attention to how are we behaving what
are our strivings do we feel hopeful
about ourselves and the world around us
and if we're interested in all of these
things we can't help but be respectful
right of just how complicated this is
like life is difficult in understanding
ourselves is is difficult you know
Wonderful Joy can come of living life
but it is hard and it's hard day by day
and trying to understand ourselves going
to these places these pillars that hold
the answers right they they can't but
making us a respect for all of it right
and the respect for ourselves for others
brings with it humility right when we
come to this point of looking at
ourselves and exploring then yes we
become empowered right because we've
gained a lot of knowledge right we're
digging where the Pay Dirt is and we're
figuring things out and along with that
empowerment comes humility a
respectfulness for how difficult all of
this is how complicated we are how we
can make happiness in our lives but how
it certainly isn't easy and we take with
us the empowerment and the humility and
we express them right and if we're
expressing empowerment and humility we
come to living through agency and
gratitude so here both are active words
so agency it's easier to see it it's an
active word where I'm aware of my
ability to to project myself into the
world around me I know that I can't
control everything right but I'm really
trying to understand what can I control
right how can I control it what do my
decisions now lead to in the future so
agency is very very active right
gratitude is active too right because
we're bringing an active sense of
gratitude since of the amazingness that
we're here and and pride in ourselves
and others for being here and and trying
to move forward as best we can and then
we bring that to our interactions we're
much more likely to have a kind gesture
towards others instead of being angry
we're much more likely to have something
compassionate to say including to
ourselves than we are to have something
angry to say that gratitude accompanies
agency their their active words and
they're active together and if we're
living life through agency and gratitude
I mean there's a lot of wisdom about
this there's a lot that's been written
and researched about this and if you
look at what is it telling us right
remember things are getting simpler
right as we're getting higher up the the
levels here right the unconscious mind
is most complicated now we're at hey can
we live our lives with agency and
gratitude at the Forefront and what does
it bring for us and I think it brings
what we are seeking that we might say
okay we're seeking happiness and that
can mean lot of things you know a lot of
different things it can be a very active
thing am I happy in the moment and we
can use happiness sometimes to distract
ourselves like happiness is important
but words when people really think like
what is it that they want or what is it
that they have right if they're they're
Overjoyed to be alive right they're
finding a sense of Peace they're finding
contentment they're finding Delight the
ability to be delighted right this is
what people want are are human history
and our our searchings tell us this in
our own experiences tell us this and and
now it could lead a person to think well
okay what's going on I mean is is this
someone who's you know levitating at the
top of a mountain like is this just a
state is this a state that people are in
and and the answer is no it'll be
sometimes we could be in that state
where we can feel peace there's no
tension inside of us right I can feel I
have times when I don't feel tension
inside of me there's contentment there's
peace I don't have to drive towards
anything right but it's not the passive
experience of it because we are living
life it's that that feeling goes hand in
hand with a drive within us that we're
when we're in this healthy place we are
living life the decisions that we're
making what is putting the rubber to the
road it is a generative Drive within us
there is a drive to make things better
to understand and to explore and it's
that drive that we access and cultivate
and synonymous with happiness is it's
not just the the state when people want
to be happy and that very very general
way yes contentment peace
Delight right but but they're happening
as we're living life right as we're
enacting a generative Drive where we're
looking at ourselves and the world
around us and we're interested in
understanding we're interested in making
things better and that's the place that
we're trying to get to I believe that
with all my with all my heart and my and
my brain my education training
experience and also experience living
living life and and for 20 years doing
this work with people tells me this is
what we're seeking and it's an active
way of of experiencing ourselves and our
place in life
I love that because it merges both the
nouns and the adjectives and the verbs
you know and and this notion of a
generative drive to me is so compelling
because
um I have the sense
and I hope I'm right that we all have
some sort of generative Drive within us
starting at an early stage
um maybe it even starts as visual
foraging or touching things with our
hands as an infant and you know
exploration of the world right is what
brings about the changes in the neural
circuitry that allow us to engage even
more and in and then progressively on
the one hand narrower ways but also with
more richness and more detail
um could you tell us more about
generative drive and and how this shows
up in different types of people
um is it always positive can there be
too much of it
um I certainly know a number of people
who are addicted to work for those of
you listening I'm raising my hand
um but I would say nowadays I'm not as
addicted to work as I once was in the
sense that I derive far more
satisfaction from
less work now provided that the work is
really in-depth you know I think that
there were years in in graduate school
where I wanted to publish a bunch of
papers and then quickly realized
um through the not so gentle persuasion
of my my mentors that like let's just do
the best possible work we can do and
there's so much more richness and
experience and things to be gained from
that so
I'm familiar with generative drive as as
I understand it but maybe if you would
if you could flesh out a bit of what
generative Drive is and does it arrive
um in parallel with or before we are
able to access peace contentment and
Delight
um Can it even be separated out from
that
um
you know what what is this generative
Drive yeah so drives are built into us
so the the synonymous with our existence
like if we exist then then we have the
drive I mean that that's how the drive
is defined right and we understand going
far back to to psychodynamic and
psychoanalytic routes and and when
people were really thinking hard about
human beings and what's going on inside
of us that we've sort of identified and
then validated over the period of time
since that we have aggressive drives
within us and we have drives towards
pleasure now this often gets
misunderstood that so aggression can be
uh it can be active violent aggression
for example but aggression can also be a
sort of a sense of agency right the
inaction of agency like I want to do
things I want to change things I want to
I want to make the world a different
place right that that all of that comes
under this drive so so aggressive an
aggressive drive is not a bad thing if
we had no aggressive drives the thoughts
we've just lie down and nothing else
would happen and then we'd all be gone
right so so there's a way in which this
drive within us moves us forward right
and of course extremely complicated the
ways we can manifest too much of it or
too little of it or how our defense
mechanisms can intertwine with the drive
but the drive is there it's like it's
fuel within us that comes with our
existence and then how that fuel moves
us forward how much of it there is no
that is determined by the meshing of the
drive with how we're living life right
and the same would be true of pleasure
you know the pleasure Drive doesn't just
mean like we all want to be hedonists
right inside it means that we want
things that are gratifying right we want
to feel good right this isn't just you
know the drive towards physical pleasure
like a sex drive or or eating food or
having Comfort like all of that can be
part of it but it's a drive for Relief
right the idea that we don't want to be
white knuckling life right searching for
pleasure so having aggression within us
as we White Knuckle life and we search
for some pleasure and relief right these
drives within us can be healthy they can
be unhealthy you know they can be
anything right they're they're
Wellsprings within us that then fuel us
forward and there's controversy to the
idea of is there a generative drive and
there's certainly at parts of the field
that do not think so right but there
have been strong thinkers in the field
that have thought we do have a
generative drive that it is within us to
look around us to be curious to be
amazed right to think like how how can I
engage with this and make this better or
happier to think outside of ourselves
right to think if I if if I feel good
and you're in pain can I make you feel
better right having nothing to do with
me right the idea of altruism coming to
the fore and having industriousness with
us within it right and and the idea that
there is a generative drive it's
strengthened when you look at how humans
behave when you know we're not
struggling right that people are
interested in learning you know you
think about how how much of people give
of themselves to learning right or to
serving others like there's so much of
this goodness in the world around us now
if we shut people away right they have
no you know imagine you know God forbid
someone is in a solitary confinement for
when they're the moment they're born you
know then there's not an opportunity for
the generative drive to thrive right and
we see so many so many situations where
it doesn't Thrive enough right you know
violence in people's surroundings lack
of opportunities right that we can
squelch a generative Drive anyone's
generative drive but if we give
ourselves opportunities if you know if
we're healthy that we're not weighed
down by trauma and illness and
misperceptions of self when we can live
life in a way that brings us to agency
and attitude now we're aligning with the
generative drive that I absolutely
believe is within us I think just look
at life look at human beings we observe
that we have this drive within us and if
that drive is at the Forefront and that
drive then naturally of course allies
with agency and gratitude then I think
we're at the place that is the place we
we ultimately seek right and that we can
find it for brief periods of time so so
by really pursuing this at like really
strongly in my own therapy and
reflection and attempts to understand I
can have periods of time where I can
feel that way I can feel outward growth
and interest in the world and and I feel
good I'm not trying to answer some
question of like why am I alive or like
I'm doing things that I feel good about
and I feel good about doing those things
and about being in the world and and I
think this is not uncommon you know it
may be far more common in societies that
are allegedly less Advanced right that
is have less distractions or maybe you
know less uh knowledge of of all the
awful things in the world that can
happen to us that are constantly fed to
us like there's a whole bunch of other
questions and topics about it but but
this this you know I have this absolute
belief that there's this generative
Drive in us that wants to Ally with
agency and gratitude and that we all
have it within us to bring those to the
Forefront and to find that thing that we
seek whether someone this person says
it's Nirvana the other person says it's
Joy or happiness or peace or numbing you
know whatever it is there's there's
something to it where we're not feeling
the tension within us we're not feeling
the anxiety the pressures but we're
feeling a sense of goodness the way
you're describing it um makes perfect
sense why peace contentment and Delight
would be so closely linked to this
generative Drive
you know the the word peace as you
alluded to is often
um brings to mind the idea of passivity
but generative drive and the inclusion
of things like aggression and the drive
for pleasure or anything but passive uh
so I think that's important uh for me
and for everyone to understand that
um Peace contentment and Delight can
really be action terms again moving them
from uh you know from the
more typical conception of them to to
verb States so peace contentment and
Delight are not passive States I mean
there can be periods of time where we
can be just very peaceful and very much
at rest but but those words are not
synonymous with inaction right in fact
they're synonymous with action a lot of
the time okay if we are suffused with
peace contentment the ability to Delight
then what we're doing is we're raising
up the generative Drive we're making
conditions that are permissive for the
generative drive to come to the
Forefront right to be Paramount over the
aggressive and the pleasure drives right
and remember we're not trying to get rid
of those drives right we just want the
generative Drive in us to be at the
Forefront then we'll be able to harness
the aggressive drive through for example
a strong sense of agency fueling the
sense of agency forward as opposed to
destructive aggression right the search
for pleasure which sure can include
physical Pleasures in in ways that are
good and reasonable and healthy for us
but also the pleasure of learning right
the pleasure that altruism brings that
we can take the aggressive drive that we
know is in us and the pleasure drive
that we know is in us and we can dial
them to the right places like this gets
very complicated and it's easy to dial
that too far up and it's easy to dial it
too far down right but if both are
serving the generative drive because we
lift up the generative drive and we
bring it to Primacy by being able to
handle Our Lives to understand ourselves
to go back to those pillars and to build
upon it the agency and the gratitude
that then leads us to peace contentment
and Delight we can put all of this
together and like we're really and truly
living in an active way in the world
that's good for us good for the world
around us and does doesn't leave us with
a sense of Yearning or sense of tension
within us
do you think it's also the case that
generative drive has kind of a um
self-amplification feature to it what
comes to mind is you're describing
generative Drive in its relationship to
peace contentment and Delight is that
approximately a half hour after I wake
up I start to feel more physically
energized I'm not somebody who just pops
out of bed and is ready to go exercise
or do mental work
but about 30 minutes or so after waking
my mind starts to wake up and I've
noticed that if I read a scientific
paper or if I read a chapter in a book
or if I do something that feels a little
bit difficult
cognitively difficult in particular that
um the sense of satisfaction that I get
from that is immense and it's not
necessarily the case that I have to
learn something that I'm going to use
that day but for me learning and um and
often learning and sharing what I learn
with the world whether or not they want
to hear it or not
um is part of my uh pleasure Loop and um
and I've learned that if I don't
capture some new knowledge in a way
that's challenging in the morning time
um I I feel like the gears are still
turning but but I start to lose energy
whereas if I find something interesting
in particular and and write it down and
and I feel like I own it that's what I
enjoy so much about learning it's like
it's in there maybe it'll be useful at
some point maybe it won't but it's like
a it's like a animal finding a tool that
it can maybe use to forage more more
effectively later in life I I get such a
sense of satisfaction that then I find
that I have immense energy to do
whatever is next like whether or not
that's exercise or learn more or prepare
a podcast or write a grant or
um or work on a paper and this feature
of my mental life has is so prominent
that
um I almost have to force myself to do
it each day and there are so many
distractions in the world nowadays that
I've come to a place where I almost have
to force myself to
do what I know works for me
um but when I do it feels like a almost
like a chemical Rocket Fuel and it
doesn't make me manic or crazy I don't
need to pick up the phone and call
somebody or tell everybody about her
post it on social media it's more of a
deep sense of satisfaction and and I get
energy from it is that the generative
Drive well it's great that that works
for you what you're saying is that for
you like you can prime your generative
drive that way right and then you prime
it you prime the pump it gets revved up
right like and then and then you know
it's it's really manifesting itself
inside of you I mean there's many
different manifestations of the
generative drive as there are people
right so something's going to work for
some person other things are going to
work for a different person right but
but but you're saying that hey I know
this thing works for me and even though
sometimes it's not easy to do I do it
and then look what it gets for me right
and that's that's really healthy right
it's like no knowing that this thing
works for you and then you become
committed to it because your generative
Drive is is is really
strongly supported by it right and then
you have this sense of Good Feeling
right so then you have you have the
peace and you have the you know just the
overall sense of goodness right the you
know peace and contentment and Delight
you're getting that and learning and in
teaching so so you you're figuring out
like hey this works for me right and
again you don't have to figure it out
through this lens it's if we find parts
that aren't working then we go back and
we figure them out right maybe a good
example maybe is um so let's say you
take someone who
acrylic enjoys gardening and gets
something out of gardening right so
there are as many generative drives and
how they're measured out as there are
humans but there can be common outcomes
of them right so the enjoyment of of
fostering plants growing a garden is
like that's not uncommon in humans right
so imagine someone who hasn't been doing
that right they really want to they have
a drive to do it there's a plot of land
in the back that they used to cultivate
right so if they're not doing it for any
number of reasons maybe maybe they were
depressed and they needed mental health
treatment maybe they just got away from
the path that they were on maybe their
defense has shifted a little bit
whatever the case may be they go back to
the pillars and they figure it out right
and now they're in accord with
themselves right and they're living
through agency and gratitude and they
feel like wait I can go back out there
and I can till that land I can I can get
the hoe out I can you know I can make
the plus I'm going to put the seeds in
I'm going to nurture like I can go go do
that and I can do it even what even
though I was depressed even though
somebody assaulted me five months ago
you know even though I lost my job even
though even though even though right
they overcome the even those right and
the sense of agency tells them right I
can go do that right and the sense of
gratitude no one who's miserable and and
now is you know is in such an awful
position about life because they were
attacked or lost their job or something
bad happened whatever it may be or
they're lost in cynicism there's no
gratitude there right it's a gratitude
for being in Life or having the
capability of going back and and
planting seeds in that Garden that's the
alliance between agency and gratitude
and then the person goes and does that
right so think of what's going on there
they do this thing they feel good about
this thing they can have they can look
out at the Garden feel some peace right
feel some contentment to them be
delighted by what they did remember how
much they loved it before how much it
means to them so yes that goodness comes
that goodness suffuses us and it raises
up the generative drives that says right
it's it's good we breathe some life into
it right enough to get that Garden done
now the generative Drive is further
fostered forward by the goodness the
person feels so so the example and the
difference between the person who's like
wants a garden feels terrible about
themselves that they're not doing it and
it feels lousy every time they look out
the window and there they are looking
out the window right the difference
between that and having made a garden
looking out the window at it is a night
and day difference and the the person
who's looking out the window at the
Garden that they build overcoming
whatever was inside of them because they
they went and addressed it and and
proved to themselves that they could
that's what we're after in life right
it's we all know this it doesn't look
like somebody levitating at the top of a
mountain right that's what it looks like
the person looking out the window at the
Garden and thinking about what they
overcome came to create the garden and
seeing the goodness of it all yeah I'm
glad you said the word creating because
it seems It's about creating things it
real tangible things but that the
process to get there is every bit as
important we're not what's created when
you create knowledge that that's
tangible right like you you create
knowledge maybe that that person looks
down the row of beautiful flowers and
has the same sense of goodness inside of
them that you do when you're we're like
right I just I just went and learned
something as you described that I I'm
thinking I I certainly hope so because
for me it's it's an incredible sense of
satisfaction and and
um one that I enjoy so much that I
almost don't want to look at it too much
because to me it it sits in this um uh
rare domain of perfect like it's just it
just feels so good and that
um and that I can get back there is very
is very comforting to me right and
that's all of this that it feels so good
that's what all this is It's the
generative drive right it's a it's the
Gratitude it's the contentment it's like
all that coming together and it's
interesting we could contrast that to to
when you talked about a repeated cycle
that's negative right then you're not
feeling that right so so think about the
learning that can come from it right
that you you can you can achieve this
and feel this and be in this state in
one aspect of your life like what can
you learn from that to bring to the
other place and more yes that's
important it's more it's often starting
with what's going on in the place that's
not doing well right like I said why the
repetition right so this is how we we
can have what we're seeking in parts of
our Lives even if we don't in others but
if we can have it in parts of our Lives
we can have it in others too and we can
become role models for ourselves we can
learn from ourselves we can learn from
what brings the good to how to raise up
the things that about us in our lives
that aren't there yet
I often get the question from the
general public how can I stop
overthinking you know I I have to
imagine based on the fact that I get
that question so often that there are a
great number of people who
um sense their own generative Drive what
are your thoughts on that
thinking can be wonderful if we're using
thinking to learn right to figure things
out so when thinking is doing that
thinking is great but a lot of thinking
is just in the service of something else
right and a lot of thinking works
against us so imagine the person making
the garden right look at the person has
to think about it if you think about
what seeds to make they have to think
about where the the tools are they have
to think about what they're doing when
they're planting when they're watering
there's a lot to do but the beauty of it
isn't in the thinking right the thinking
is in the service of what is generative
right so so that's a different kind it's
it's just thinking in the service of
something but a lot of our thinking is
that you know it's it's planning it's
projecting we tend to glorify the
planning and the projecting and and it
can be great when we're learning when
we're figuring things out but a lot of
that is is there so that we can do the
things that are good for us to do right
the planning and the projecting around
making the garden where the point of it
is the garden it's not the thinking part
right we can also use thinking against
us so much thinking is repetitive and
and not just not just unproductive but
harmful right that person who's looking
out the window at the Garden may be
thinking I mean sometimes they're just
pauses in our thinking but you know a
lot of times the person must be thinking
and and what often goes on there is just
repetitive negative thinking it's
you know gosh I used to have a garden I
remember when that was beautiful or you
know remember before
such and such a person passed away and
then we stopped making the Garden or
I'll never be able to make a garden
again or gosh it's too much you know
it's just something that's negative and
unproductive I mean what else is there
to think if the person's actually
looking out the window at the Garden
right and they're in this sort of stuck
state they're not in a generative State
and the thinking becomes becomes
repetitive and it furthers all the
negative right she said The more we
further the negative the more we take if
there's a four-lane highway that we want
to atrophy unless I make it into a
six-lane highway you know but but we do
that when when we have this repetitive
thinking which then can evolve into the
narratives the things that we say to
ourselves right so so your thinking is
wonderful it's wonderful but it can also
just observe something else and it can
also be used against us so what we're
talking about here doesn't glorify
thinking I mean it does if it's in the
service of the generative drive but it
doesn't in and of itself
I think many people
um
set a time say you know 9 30 a.m or 10
a.m when they are going to begin doing
something that they want to do or know
they should do that's a little bit
challenging it could be exercise could
be cognitively demanding work
and then 10 o'clock rolls around they
say okay 10 15. and they're distracted
by often social media texting these days
I think those are the main culprits
really
um I don't know too many people that get
distracted by exercise and reading books
some do
um and doing complex puzzles or math but
um you know social media is a little bit
like mental chewing gum except that I
would add to that that's the kind of
chewing gum that um really does shake
the appetite in a way that prevents you
from eating nutritious food unless used
correctly right
um and then people feel
bad about themselves because the whole
morning went by
now it's noon then they require some
food like any uh typical person right
and they eat then they might need a
little nap for the Post perennial dip
and energy and then the afternoon and
then it goes on and on I mean I I hear
this all the time I've experienced this
before so I'm not immune to this myself
that's why I try and capture that early
wave of energy whatever it might be
adrenaline nor adrenaline uh
some combination the way you describe
thinking and its potential relationship
to generative Drive
it seems to me it's so important that we
capture those moments of potential
creation however small the action might
be to remind ourselves that we are
capable of moving things from point A to
point B
because in the description I just gave
of the person that lets the morning
Escape
there's there's really
um no external barrier except these
distractions but differently all the
tools exist within most all of us to be
able to create what we want to create or
at least to create something right I
mean that right
um and yet many many people just don't
fulfill that
um that right that they were and that
we've all been given right so let's
think about what's going on there right
so so the person that I'm going to
exercise at 10 o'clock right now and
push it back to 10 15 and they do
something on social media or they push
it back to 10 30 it'll be okay I'll get
it all in what they're doing is they're
they're engaging in is unhealthy defense
mechanisms right so if we go back to the
the pillars right the the structure of
self the function of self there may be
other reasons for it but let's just
identify the unhealthy defenses of
avoidance and rationalization right and
then there's no thinking going on about
that right religious unconscious
processes and you kick it down you know
you kick it down the clock 15 minutes
right they're not thinking about it
thinking then is subserving something
different right the thinking is
subserving the avoidance if I'm going to
go look on something and read a couple
of things reply you know I'm thinking
I'm planning right I got to get the
maybe I got to get the phone out I gotta
tap you know my code into it I got to go
to a certain website like you were doing
something that we're thinking about it I
think about what I'm going to write back
but the thinking is all in the service
of the unhealthy defenses right so then
by understanding ourselves better we can
we can bring that right to a healthier
Place how by by actually using thinking
for what helps us right so let's think
of like what okay what's going let's say
if you're doing that okay what's going
on when you're doing that right so so do
you you really want to exercise right
but like it's not easy to exercise and
sometimes maybe just problem solving are
you doing a thing you like maybe
something you like more there's lower
barrier Etc but let's say a we're just
working within the psychological right
then you can come at that a couple of
ways like I don't want to do that thing
that thing's hard right I mean I think
that about things in my life sometimes
and it always makes me happy makes me
weighty and unhappy right I may as well
put 20 pound weights on either side of
me right I mean I can look at it that
way right or there's a different way of
looking at it that actually fits much
better which is like I'm not daunted by
doing difficult things and I can get out
there and apply myself and you know and
I feel good about that when I do
difficult things it's like part of my
identity right it's like part of how I
see myself so right I'm gonna go do this
thing and I'm going to feel good about
it and isn't it amazing that I get to do
it right like look here I am I'm alive
I'm healthy right I can go do this thing
my health is is good but I want to make
it better right by working out or I'm at
least alive and if I lose a little bit
of weight I'll feel healthier like come
on this is good right and then I'll feel
different about that right and like the
truth is one or the other it's like oh
both can be true now what will be true
is what you choose right and if you
choose the negative then yes the
unhealthy defense is perpetuate and even
if you get yourself to do it today it's
harder to do it tomorrow that's why
sometimes I'll say to a person like just
take a look at it and decide if you want
to do it or not if you don't want to
exercise just decide you don't
right and then okay there's a trade-off
for everything maybe you're okay with
the trade-off right but what am I trying
to do there right is is bring to
Consciousness that that person is making
a choice right do you want to do it if
you want to do it if you want to do it
it's great to just do it right and if
you don't it's great to not do it unless
you're being honest and clear with
yourself and you're not wasting all that
time when you keep kicking it 15 minutes
down the you know down the clock you
know until it's too late does does that
make sense that's I think how the
structure here really does it works
because it's it's pulling together what
we know from the biology to the
psychology of like how to understand
ourselves and how to understand when
things aren't the way we want them to be
so that we can make them the way we want
them to be it's not magic it's it's
following this sort of mathematical
aspects of you know going to the factors
assessing them making changes and and
then of course we see the outcome we
want to see the way you describe it does
make sense and I appreciate it because I
think ultimately it seems to ratchet
back to actions to verbs to bring us to
these feeling states that you know I
think are what people are seeking you
know peace contentment Delight you know
through agency gratitude as active terms
right yes you know I think these are
Universal desires and again you're
providing this um wonderful road map for
people to arrive there thank you I do
have a question about some of the
underpinnings of generative Drive in
particular this notion of aggressive
Drive
um I've known people that seem to have a
lot of this I just have a lot of get up
and go or a lot of drive to create in
the world or to figure things out they
often do create great lives for
themselves in in work and relationship
Etc I've also observed that these people
often don't have the best relationship
to themselves or that they run up
against barriers or frankly sometimes
straight into brick walls in certain
domains of their life perhaps as a
consequence of having too much of this
generative or aggressive Drive
and at the same time I know that there
are people in the world many that have
what seems to be a low generative Drive
I don't know if that's the case or not
but
um that they
um they seem to have a hard time
engaging like in doing things and and
often you get the impression that they
somewhat are completely given up
like it's just like life is just too
hard or
um sometimes it's even more subtle like
I know someone who they like their job
but they've ever come to the place that
um you know like it's just work like
it's a paycheck and that might be enough
but they're always talking about it so I
have to assume that it's not enough they
aren't able to slot their work into one
domain and just focus on the other uh
aspects of their life that are going
well it doesn't compensate for them to
think about the other aspects of their
life that is so
um is there a Continuum of generative
drives that exist in us are these
intrinsic I realize there are near
infinite number of conditions that could
give rise to one or the other
could be hardwired could be nature it
could be nurture but what is the
relationship between kind of um I want
to say arousal or a potential for
arousal and aggressive drive and uh and
these things that we're seeking yeah
yeah so if it's okay I I I'd like to
start like the first principles of the
drives right so the theory of drives
came about when when people were
observing very closely like human beings
and human behavior individuals uh
societies cultures right and and
identifying that hey that you can boil a
lot of things down to to a drive that we
call aggressive right there's something
to like impose myself out there on the
world around me right it explains a lot
of what people do right and then the
other identified Drive was pleasure
right who was you know so enjoyment even
relief of unpleasantness right that the
thoughts like you can describe a lot of
human behavior and and that to
understand like what's going on inside
of us that means that we're here right
you see that through the lens of
aggressive and pleasure drives and like
that's the answer to it to how we
survive but I think that is not the
answer to it that if it were just
aggressive drives and pleasure drives
there's not a value system around that
like you know somebody who's very
industrious can build or destroy right
and we see this in historical figures
like being very intelligent and very
industriousness has nothing to do with
whether you're building or destroying
right so if it were just an aggressive
drive and a pleasure drive then we
wouldn't be having this conversation
right because the species would have
would not have survived right so if you
believe that and I believe that then you
look for something else you say maybe we
looked and we found two things and there
are more things right and then we start
thinking about learning for learning's
sake altruism things that are not
explained right unless there's a
self-referential will you feel good
doing something for someone else so
therefore it's selfish like there's a
lot of gyrations around that if you
really observe humans you do see
altruism altruism you see learning for
learning's sake you see people being
benign when everything about a situation
would say that they could would or
should under society's rules not be
benign right and then we start to see
that there is another drive that how do
you explain that we're here yeah
aggression pleasure and generativeness
regenerative Drive the drive to make
things better that's why we build more
than we destroy we destroy a lot right
but we build more than we destroy
otherwise we wouldn't have clothes on
our backs let alone have the the
technology to sit here and to be able to
do this so it's the generative drive
that that is most realized in the
healthy person right and the healthy
person has the strong generative drive
now as you said there are other factors
and this is sort of what you were asking
about they're probably they're natural
levels of aggression or pleasure seeking
or generativeness that differ across
people right because we're a product of
you know the complexity of our genetics
and you know all the complexities of
Nature and nurture so we're going to get
to a place where where some of us have
more some of us have less right the the
the the the conclusion though is for all
of us the generative Drive being at the
helm is what what leads us to be to live
good lives right to live to the things
that we aspire to the peace and
contentment right so we want the
generative drive to Rule the Day right
whether a person is studying
Neuroscience or growing gardens right
the importance is about being generative
then then aggression and pleasure can
subserve the generative drive right and
then the question you're asking I think
which is well what if there's too much
aggression too little aggression right
or too much pleasure seeking too little
pleasure seeking that's when we we can
see problems right and the problems then
lead us back to the pillars to figure
out the problems so too much aggression
ultimately becomes Envy right too much
aggression means like I want I I want to
impose myself on the on the world around
me more than I can more than is
reasonable more than I can do without
impinging upon others right that what
you end up doing is taking from others
right too much aggression becomes
destructive right maybe a person
destroys tear something down right takes
from others uh says that the the nasty
comment when it wasn't necessary and now
everyone feels bad right right there's
that too much aggression start it
becomes Envy right and envy is
destructive right the same thing with
too much pleasure seeking if I say okay
I want you know I want my fair share of
pleasure and you know relief of distress
and all that but if I start if I rely on
that too much right we're now instead of
aggression eclipsing degenerative drive
now it's pleasure eclipsing the
generative drive then I want more
pleasure and more pleasure and more
pleasure and how long before I want your
pleasure right so so then it's not
healthy right what it becomes is envious
right it becomes destructive because now
then I become Covetous of your pleasure
or if I can't get it but I could bring
you down then I'll feel better about
myself that's Envy right so too much
aggression eclipsing degenerative drive
too much of the of pleasure seeking to a
pleasure Drive eclipsing the generative
drive and we end up in places of envy
and envy is destructive and now we're in
trouble I've never thought before about
the relationship between aggression
pleasure and envy but as you're
describing it it comes to mind the movie
American Psycho where Christian Bale
plays this well basically an 80s Yuppie
in you know working in finance in New
York and um and for anyone that's seen
it it's a can only be described as a
violent parody of of 80s Yuppie culture
and it's comedy as there's going to be
yeah it's as dark a comedy as it could
be and and don't let your young children
watch it because it's very gruesome and
it has and like very sexual and but the
the the the aggressive features within
the character that Bale plays
um are immediately apparent in the movie
like you know violent aggression sexual
aggression
um seeking money seeking wealth all the
time a narcissism to an obsession with
like everything from his skin care
routine to uh his eight pack abs and
like it's it's ridiculous but um but
also an interesting window into some
milder forms of those features that
still exist in many people today right
um but the Envy component starts to
reveal itself a little bit later into
the movie where
um the scene I recall is one around
where someone hands them a business card
and then you hear the narrative in his
own mind about how much nicer that guy's
business card has been his and how he
hates him so much he ends up killing the
guy yes in very violent and sadistic
fashion that's aggression over
generative that's right right and so and
the whole movie is about
um this one uh aspect of culture at that
time's ability to impose their will on
ever everyone at at their whim you know
basically Bell just does whatever the
hell he wants at any point goes returns
videotapes in between and you know and
there's so much woven into it and uh
that is relevant and so much that's
woven into it that's just purely for
people's kind of sick entertainment um
uh but that I believe it was Brett Brent
Easton Ellis that wrote that and you
know it's tapping into the the
aggression component the pleasure
component but the Envy component is
really what resonates as as you come to
the end of the movie is like there's no
satisfying this guy he could kill her or
sleep with as many people as he wants in
the movie
um and he can have as much wealth as he
wants he can have entire buildings in
fact I think he's living in an entire
building at some point he takes over
people's Apartments after he kills them
it's it's it's wild and disgusting
um but it really speaks to the extent to
which Envy is woven into absolutely
aggression and pleasure seeking and it's
not something that had really sunk in
for me until you describe it now
um because I think for most people they
imagine okay when somebody has X number
of
millions or billions of dollars that
they'll reach this place of Peace
contentment and Delight right they'll
have enough
um and in the movie Wall Street there's
that one
scene where someone says you know what's
your number like at what point is it
enough and the guy says more that says
all sorts of things about the
dopaminergic system of reward systems in
the brain Etc but I think it says a lot
more about envy and just what and what a
pit of despair Envy is for everybody
involved right right look Envy may not
be the root of all evil but Envy plus
natural disasters Maybe
so much
evil and destruction arises from envy
and it may be that it's at the root of
all of it and we so under appreciate
that right we so underappreciate why
people are destructive right which is
why the roots aren't always in trauma
but but a significant uh uh aspect of of
where Envy arises from can often be
trauma creating a sense of guilt and
shame and vulnerability but but wherever
a person may come by it and it's a
larger discussion of envy and where it
may come from is it drives destruction
and if the aggressive Drive is greater
than the generative drive or if the
pleasure Drive is greater than the
generative drive or if both are greater
than the generative drive it will drive
destruction
and that destruction the vast majority
of times if you look deep enough you
find at its roots envy that Envy may
arise from guilt and shame within the
person but as soon as it becomes about
another right I feel guilt and shame and
inadequacy inside of me but then I feel
Envy of those around me it drives the
vast majority of Destruction
do you think that's what's happening
when we see these um sadly ever more
frequent examples of
um active Shooters and school shootings
things of that sort yes there are there
are other people who have life
right and that person doesn't feel
that they do so they want to go and take
it
away from them right that's why as long
as we have human tribulation and a lot
of Guns is is going to happen it's it's
a it's a logical conclusion of enough
people being in places of Despair and
how Envy can be cultivated within us and
then ultimately how it blinds people it
creates such a desire for Destruction
that then people will take life away
from others and often if people will
sometimes take their own life which
which I think really brings to the
Forefront like that that person doesn't
feel that they have a life certainly not
a life worth preserving so they're then
going to take the lives of others and I
think we're seeing that is as Stark
a portrait of where Envy can lead I
think as we can find on a one-person
basis we can go we can look at Wars and
their destruction on a societal basis
but I think that's that's the ultimate
in understanding where and we can drive
a person
what about the other end of the spectrum
when aggression and pleasure seeking are
too low the other side of the spectrum
is demoralization right so let's imagine
very very low aggression so low
self-assertion low agency there there
comes a place where the person is not
then
imposing themselves or believing that
they can in in much of any way on the
outside world and that creates a sense
of isolation understandably right a
sense of powerlessness and vulnerability
and isolation and that then becomes
demoralizing which is not the same as
depression I mean you know we know
depression is a it is there's a
neurochemical imbalance right whether
that imbalance came purely biologically
or came psychologically or because of
external events there's a neurochemical
imbalance you know here we're not
talking about an illness
State as identified by modern Psychiatry
there's not a number in the in the book
of diagnoses that goes along with with
being demoralized right but why because
it's a state that humans can be in and
too low of an aggressive drive right and
all the things that come of that it's
isolating and it's demoralizing the same
with too low of a of a pleasure drive so
an example that may be relatable is
um to some people is you know knowing
someone who who has had a couple of
really bad breakups and and then says oh
I'm not you know what I'm done with that
there's no more Romance I'm going to be
single right and you know like that
person has a drive in them like you know
they're an interconnected person like
they they want romance so they these are
things that are important to them but
they they make a decision I'm I'm not
going to have that in my in my life what
would be called in some psychodynamic
senses inviting death into life a little
bit of death by by swearing off
something that that the person has a
drive towards right the pleasure Drive
of companionship and of romance right
that that then becomes demoralizing as
well so sure those things demoralization
can predispose to depression but
demoralization is a thing in and of
itself is where then there's a sense of
hopelessness there's a sense of you know
the goodness then is inaccessible
anymore and that's the other side of
Envy can low levels of aggression
and the resulting demoralization
be coupled with high levels of pleasure
seeking so I'm thinking about the person
that um you know is like very overweight
clearly
um headed for health issues if they
don't already have them and
you know perhaps would like to remove
that weight would like to feel more
vigorous doesn't want type 2 diabetes
and an early death but at some level
they've given up but because the the
pleasure of eating is something they
really enjoy they really love it and yet
it has a component to it in their life
where they either self-soothed with it
or they're just trying to hit Baseline
levels of satisfaction with it and and
um they allow themselves to effectively
be sedentary and and then the other
sorts of trouble start to show up you
know sleep apnea from carrying excessive
weight and then they're feeling tired
during the day and then who can exercise
when they're too tired when you got to
work and maintain other life demands and
you can kind of see where this could
arise and makes perfect sense
um you can also see where
um if there were just a little bit more
aggression it could all be turned around
but they don't have it so is the
scenario describe something that you've
seen clinically I certainly observe it
in my non-clinical stance out there in
the world a lot right well I think the
most important thing you're pointing out
is that aggression and pleasure on the
high end right we we know can Trump the
generative drive right but that this can
also happen on the low end right so
you're describing a situation since it's
a great example right because it's not
uncommon in the world around us so the
aggression meaning the fuel to put
oneself out there in the world right to
utilize the sense of agency right so
this is going to be a person who's low
agency right the aggressive drive it has
as little fuel than to give the sense of
agency it's further squelched by
negative by you know negative sense of
self and negative self-talk now you find
where the the aggressive Drive is is too
low and too low low can also Trump the
generative drive right because then that
person can't take care of themselves a
generative drive would say there's a lot
of life to live in there can be great
things in life and take better care of
yourself and by the way they're like
people that you love and people that
love you or or if not you know there's
an animal regarding you love right so so
the generative drives is saying that
right but it's not winning the day
because the the aggression or you know
aggression is one word we could put to
that drive you could call it an
assertion drive you know we call it an
agency drive but that's you know we're
using agency in a different way but that
thing is too low so it wins out over the
generative drive and then in the example
you gave it's not surprising that the
pleasure Drive goes the other way maybe
there's a predisposition to that
genetically maybe it's just reinforced
because a person in that place could say
well think of what what this the the
self-conception would be right I'm in
this terrible place
um it you know means I'm a terrible
person I can't make myself better or I'm
not good enough to get better no one
cares about me I can't make anything
right so so therefore like I don't I
don't matter it's no reason to take care
of myself so why would I not do if I eat
that one thing that I enjoy and it gives
me pleasure even it gives me pleasure
for two minutes then I'll eat another
one like in a sense so what well because
I don't feel that I'm worth preserving
or that I can preserve myself right
there's a nihilism to it that then kind
of makes it make sense to overindulge
the pleasure Drive whether it's a
whether it's biologically predisposed or
one is just arriving there but the the
reason all that is bad
is because the aggressive Drive is too
low and in fact it's low enough that
it's outweighing the generative drive
then the pleasure Drive is going to come
into you know one place or another if
it's also really low the person does not
much of anything and wastes away which
tragically happens a lot in our society
right or if the pleasure Drive is high
maybe that person overindulges in things
that provides short-term gratification
and then that causes a different set of
problems but but what's deterministic
there is whether whether aggression or
assertion again we could put different
words to that drive but what we've been
calling the aggressive drive and the
pleasure Drive are they is one or the
other or both high enough to Trump the
generative drive or low enough to Trump
the generative drive and and I think all
problems that we see like everything
fits into this model because it honors
what we know right it honors what we
know about human behavior and insights
into human behavior over hundreds of
years right over thousands of years
right the wisdom that really brings
forward and it honors the science and
that's why it fits together because I
think it honors who we are as what are
species is what we are
um and you know what it's like what life
is like as as we try and engage with it
yeah I've seen cases of demoralized
people where uh
they simply you know disappear they hide
they isolate they slow down they take
terrible care of their health and um you
know sadly I've known uh several people
like this in my lifetime uh one of whom
killed himself the the other who just
has an immense number of health problems
related to overeating and
um inactivity and and knows it and talks
about it and but nothing seems to change
despite multiple interventions from a
caring standpoint from Friends Etc
I've also seen examples of people who
are demoralized who seem to band with
other demoralized people sort of try to
recalibrate the standard that they feel
um oppresses them you know that they and
this isn't necessarily just in the realm
of physical fitness this is also in the
realm of like School demands I I went to
a very demanding High School
as I've talked about before on a couple
of podcasts I barely finished high
school I was not an attentive student I
was my um
aggressive and pleasure drives went into
a non-academic Endeavors and I regret
that you know I had so much making up of
of learning to do by time I
unfortunately got to college eventually
caught up but
um my experience of high school was that
there were these you know kids scoring
perfectly on the s.a.t and the early
admission to Harvard and early admission
to Yale and all these places and then
there was you know a distribution in the
middle and then there was a collection
of of kids who were not doing well knew
they weren't doing well and kind of
banded together around the idea of not
doing well I I didn't consider myself
part of that group because I I frankly
wasn't there that often and and
um I was focused on other things as I
mentioned but but
what came of that group was actually
quite tragic not just for them but for a
lot of other people they uh eventually
engaged it wasn't a school shooting type
scenario but they eventually you know
set off explosives in the on the school
campus this was after they had graduated
um I don't know where they are nowadays
but things did not go well for them and
they
um exerted a lot of uh destruction to
other people around them but before they
did that there was this kind of banding
together around their the fact that they
didn't fit in that they and they weren't
bullied as I recall that I could be
wrong about this but I've seen this in
other forms too like you know if you
can't meet the standard band up with
other people and change the standard and
then you don't feel as demoralized
perhaps
um I can understand I can rationalize
why this would be a a reasonable
approach but
um
I'm seeing this more and more
um I'm also seeing by the way you know
the other end of the spectrum people are
overly aggressive and pleasure seeking
and things of that sort but for for the
moment I'd like to um your thoughts on
you know how demoralization can split
off into different Expressions depending
on how
um people feel and who else they're
relating to yeah yeah well I think the
place I would start is to say like our
society Russia's headlong forward in a
way that causes our society to trample
people who are vulnerable and vulnerable
people are demoralized people
demoralized people are vulnerable people
and our society often tramples them and
then they're not here with us any longer
and that is tragic but at times they
don't get trampled they get cast aside
right they they they're injured right
and cast aside and from that place
tragic things happen right people then
stay isolated you know I think it's a
tragedy that we don't all band together
and go door to door right to like seek
people who who aren't coming out of
doors right you know in the sense of
like we let people be so so isolated and
and oftentimes that's that's the tragic
end of someone's story right
um sometimes people do engage right
either demoralized but they can engage
in in ways that involve an affiliative
defense so sometimes people who are
demoralized can affiliate they can band
together in in ways as I think you were
alluding to that can that can make
things better so if people are
demoralized because say they're a a
group in society that that is
chronically very mistreated right then
it can be very powerful to band together
both because there's what's called an
affiliative defense that if I feel bad
about myself about something and I'm
alone it's highly likely I'm going to
continue feeling bad about myself about
that thing right but if you feel bad
about yourself about the same thing and
then work together right we help each
other feel better we don't feel so
lonely we don't alone we don't feel so
isolated we don't feel so ashamed right
so an affiliative defense can help
people to to say wait a second like I'm
not there's nothing wrong with me and
I'm not gonna take this lying down or
something right and then and to to make
assertions that create better rights in
the world around us so so like very good
things can happen from from affiliation
in the context of demoralization but
very bad things can happen too right
because people can also affiliate around
things that are very destructive I mean
if I am hateful of society and I would
like to be destructive and I'm alone
okay I could do destructive things alone
but if I band together with a couple
other people who feel that way and now
I'm empowered to feel that way right
instead of maybe I feel that way and or
or there's racism or Prejudice and I
don't feel like I can say that right but
then when it's permissive right because
other people are are in the same place
then people can accentuate the hatred
within you know within them so
affiliation is very very powerful and
part of society rushing so headlong
forward and either trampling or
marginalizing people is that we then
don't pay attention or not enough
attention to what happens with the
affiliative groups right how do you
guide people towards towards being able
to affiliate in ways that are productive
how do you give them routes of being
productive right how do you try and
protect against the ways that
affiliation can lead to destructive
Behavior so I think you know a lot of
this is these are the natural things
that happen within us but a lot of what
we're talking about now gets impacted a
lot by society and societal standards
which we of course all together you know
you determine right and arise from us
but they they start to sort of transcend
because it's now people interacting with
a whole social system
going back to the other end of the
spectrum
excess aggression
in particular uh I was in a conversation
with somebody recently it was very
successful like
Beyond most people's comprehension of
successful financially successful and
seems to just have you know checked off
their their goals one one box at a time
you know from from go
um but who described his
um underlying
psychology and emotional state as
um one in which
much of what he does on a day-to-day
basis is driven by aggression in fact he
uh volunteered an anecdote about the
fact that um he hates early morning
meetings on Zoom but he shows up to them
as sort of a uh like an Fu towards
somebody that might not even be on the
meeting right and um and so there's a
friction point for him that allows him
to engage in a way that he wouldn't
otherwise be able to engage and he he
channels that towards productivity and
clearly it's worked for him
uh you know I don't know if he's done
the sort of introspective uh deep dive I
imagine no through the structure of self
and function of self but you know what
are we to make of of that sort of
example I mean I I like the idea that if
someone has a strong aggressive drive
that they would Channel it toward good I
mean I have no reason to think this
person is doing anything but good in the
world for themselves and others
certainly not harming anyone at least
not to my knowledge
but that seems like a rough place to
live
for me it seems like a rough place to
live and at the same time I'll offer a
very brief anecdote that you know at one
point in my career namely when I was a
postdoc I was in a position by virtue of
having left a laboratory in the nature
of the field at the time where the work
I wanted to do was directly pitted
against the work of another very
powerful Laboratory
except that I was alone postdoc working
in a laboratory essentially on my own on
this problem and I remember going to my
postdoc advisor the late Ben Barris and
saying you know I think it might just
move to a different problem
because I don't really want to go up
against this Goliath and he said uh you
know this is the best uh you know I can
capture Ben's voice he said they're
absolutely not like there's no way you
love this stuff you have to do it
because you love it and he kept telling
me how much I love it and he reminded me
that indeed I did love the questions and
once I was able to tap back into the
love for and the Curiosity around the
questions
I was able to push aside the the
concerns enough that we did well
um in publishing certain papers they did
well but those five years frankly were a
lot less pleasureful than they could
have been I think because much of the
script in my head was that I was in
friction with this like you know at
least in my mind this oppressive force
it was it was purely competitive and I
truly believe that we can't be at in our
most creative state when we are
competing with someone else by
definition because then you're you're
creating against a standard as opposed
to Raw Creation right so
um in both cases a lot of aggressive
Drive frankly I I have some of that and
I had that
um but a desire for Revenge a component
of friction mixed in you know or
integrated with this aggressive drive
like this picture like even as I
describe it is you know causing the
release of a little little bit of
adrenaline it's it's not a comfortable
State it's not it can't be a state of
Happiness right so as you said people
can do good in the world they can do not
good in the world like we're not making
value judgment about what the person is
doing because that's not what the
question is about right like how are
they feeling how are they doing right
what's going on inside of them right and
that can't be happy right that can't be
happy because if if if you're built to
be pretty good at competition right so
you can size up what are the factors you
know you can strategize right so a
person is built to be really good at
competition
then you know it sounds pretty good to
make everything a competition right
because you you have the highest winning
percentage right and but that's that's
good to achieve some end right that
doesn't have any feeling intrinsically
associated with it right and if all
you're doing is a series of competitions
and what you're doing then is winning
right and like winning is something like
you know winning is like I won I beat
you whatever that is like that that can
be part of happiness but it doesn't have
to be right that's not happiness right
so so yes that kind of I'm I'm really
built to compete well and I'm gonna just
see a series of competitions in front of
me that's it for for expedient forward
progress right that's very effective but
again expedient forward progress is is
nothing to do with peace contentment
delay like it's it's not you know it
doesn't have anything to do with that in
order to have anything to do with doing
good or bad right and I think the
example you gave in your own in your
career is like it's such a good example
right because you know if you think
about it when the way that you were sort
of framing it inside is like there's a
question I'm asking there's a question
they're asking right and there's a
competition right and again it has to be
too too to compete right so so there's
almost an automaticity right that like
you're studying the same thing maybe you
know they feel competitive or certain
people there too they were were and are
definitely competitive they know who
they are they're extremely and very
successful okay so then so then
I'm in a competition now again but you
never decided to be in a competition
right but but automatically right I mean
it's interesting right to understand
you're acting as if you're in a
competition because I don't want this
competition right because like they're
bigger than me it's gonna be unpleasant
it's going to take you away from really
thinking about what you want to do right
it's going to make it harder to do a
good to do the job you want to do right
because now you're embroiled in you know
something that's you know that has
aggression behind it right so so you
choose no I don't I choose not to do
that right and then Ben Barris reframes
it to the truth and says well this this
isn't this is not a competition
because you're not choosing to compete
right because Ben pointed out what was
important to you was the questions right
so it's like almost as if Ben remind you
no no this is not through the aggressive
Drive look at it through the generative
drive that's what wins out in you right
and then
you go and apply yourself to it yeah and
bless him for doing it because uh from
that point forward I I've made it my
um firm mission to always do things from
a place of what I was thinking about as
Delight you know curiosity Delight the
things that give me energy and that give
me more energy from doing them
um it wasn't a coincidence I believe
that in those five years when I was
operating from a mix of generative drive
and the competition would then resurface
and you know I couldn't hold it constant
that um I was absolutely exhausted by
the end of that phase I just in a way
that
um sucked a lot of the pleasure out of
it I still derived some pleasure but
then as I mentioned fortunately I was
able to
pivot back to doing things out of love
you know and and and getting back to uh
peace contentment and especially Delight
right you know right and I absolutely
make a value judgment about that right
that what you did is better right so
what if you did what if you were
different so think about if we talk
about it through this accurate lens what
if you were different at that time and
the aggressive Drive in you was greater
than the generative Drive in you right
which would be an unhealthy state to be
in but let's say you were in that
unhealthy State then you probably would
have still done what you did but you
would have done it through the lens of
aggression like I'm gonna get them right
now you're competitive with them there's
there's anger in you there's you know
there's aggression right that you're
enacting in fantasy as you're you know
you're thinking about them and how
you're going to win like all sorts of
things go on inside of us and I would
say there's no way on Earth you could
have done the science as well as you did
right it couldn't be because all that
stuff is distracting right it's you know
that kind of negative yeah affect pools
for energy and time from you and also
what seeds would you have planted in the
the microcosm that you operate in right
more more competition right more
competitiveness more Badness right so
let's look at what you did do right
because
you're healthy or this particular
question about this particular thing we
know for sure because your generative
Drive eclipses the aggressive drive then
you set yourself to the work in a way
that's going to be more effective right
your brain isn't clouded you're not
wasting energy you know plotting some
revenge or plotting what you're going to
do if they come take something from your
lab I mean whatever it is you know like
you're not living in any of that so
you're going to do a better job at what
you're what's so important to you to do
and what seeds are you sowing then right
you're sowing seeds of collaboration
right and even then if someone could say
well what does even that matter right
say well it doesn't matter because what
you're doing then we just follow for the
math of it right is contributing to
understanding that's contributing to
human health right and the better
understanding we have of human health
the more people stay alive and the more
people stay healthy which could mean any
one of us just like any one of us could
be the vulnerable person that Society
tramples or casts aside we all have it
in us to be that or have been that at
stages of our lies right we also all
have it in us to be the opposite of that
right we have it in us to be generative
we have it in us to make good we have it
in us to contribute to health to
survival and that I place a value
judgment upon it's why doing good is
better than doing bad why creating is
better than destroying and why
ultimately it's the generative drive
that has to Trump the other drives and
when it does we're happy we're healthy
we make the world a better place we Ally
with and are suffused with the Gratitude
and agency in us are fully active and
we're suffused with peace contentment
Delight as you said that's the place to
be from that place we get this thing
that we want and we help to make the
world a better place which helps us to
keep the thing we want
it sounds so simple because as you
pointed out the manifestations of
looking at the right things and doing
the right things
are so simple yes right it's it's a list
really and again we have a PDF that
includes this list and and the the
structure of of the pillars and how they
flow up to this list but ultimately it's
peace contentment and Delight you know
undergirded by agency and gratitude as
active terms I mean very simple at some
level
um
and yet for many people including myself
at certain times in life the the um
excess or or a lack of aggressive drive
or excess or lack of pleasure Drive
can interfere with people's ability to
access these these simple but um
incredibly powerful being States
because it's nature and nurture right so
I you might be built with a a greater or
lesser natural amount of one drive than
I am right but then we've had life
experience that creates a Delta around
that right so so you say okay we're
built with different amounts of all
these drives yes yes we are right but we
also have control right through our
decisions through how we handle Our
Lives to modulate them right so if that
makes sense because the thought could be
well the drive is what the drive is and
it varies across people no there's a
range the drive is in and that range can
be very broad I mean people can do all
sorts of things to cultivate to
cultivate the better we all can right so
if we look at it as an unlimited upside
right then what we what we see is I want
to know where they at in me now right
what's going on inside of me what are
all those other factors right because I
want to cultivate the good I want to
cultivate that generative drive and I
want to make sure the aggression and the
pleasure aren't out of balance one way
or another like we can actively look at
that and manage it and I think that's
like so what we're striving for because
there's nothing here that we don't have
some control over right and the higher
we get up right the simpler it gets the
more we have control over it
and for people who feel like the the
ideals that we're providing a road map
toward are not accessible for whatever
reason maybe they're feeling a little
bit or a lot demoralized uh overly
aggressive and not ending up where they
want to go or ending up where they want
to go and not experiencing deep
satisfaction peace contentment and
Delight
where should they look in this framework
that includes these pillars at the Deep
levels of structure of cell function of
self that you know give rise to
empowerment humility agents see
gratitude peace contentment to light you
if someone should find themselves
unmotivated or or stuck you know uh
metaphorically speaking staring out the
window into the garden that could be and
that they want so very much but that
they're not creating again that should
translate to whatever domain of life
you're you're seeking or not even in
touch with what you really want you know
infinitely confused about what to do in
relationship school work life
you know and and thinking about all the
oppressive forces in the world like the
political Chasm and the you know
pandemics and lockdowns and like and all
the stuff and all the things that are
weighing down on us
what should that person in other words
what should we all do at that moment you
know stop and what
each pillar has five cupboards look in
all five
and follow the clues that you find there
that's the answer
so go back to
structure of cell function of self ask
questions about and engage in practices
that bring about more self-awareness
practices that
um draw our attention to what's Salient
for us ask ourselves you know what am I
thinking about internally what is my
internal script what it what am I
focusing on externally you know am I
spending all day on Twitter looking at
accounts that I know I hate because it
activates something in me etc etc
I might have revealed something about
myself I'm just kidding that's not my my
behavior but I see a lot of other people
doing it what are my behavioral choices
you know
um what could bring about more
hopefulness and striving
there's so much of this that say one
could do on one's own right because we
can think about ourselves and we can
learn things if we say I don't really
know that much about defense mechanisms
okay like we could read about it right
like we can do a lot of this on our own
and we can get so much from talking to
other people you know people in our
Lives who are close to us who love us
right we can talk with them about what's
going on inside of us right and that is
such an amazing mechanism of learning
and they're also Professional Resources
I mean like good therapy should
Encompass like this should be what it's
doing right it might come out through
one lens or another lens and you know
because every everybody's different and
we can bring different modalities but
ultimately that's what good therapy is
doing right it's looking in all 10 of
those cupboards and it's seeing where is
the issue let's follow the clues like
it's a spirited inquiry right whether
we're doing it on our own or we're doing
it with other people in our personal
lives or we're doing it with someone
professionally it's a spirited inquiry
to follow the clues because if we follow
the clues there are answers right and if
we have the answers then we can bring
things into better alignment and then
we're in a better place those pillows
are more stable and we can build on top
of them what we want to build on top of
them and the drives come better into
line that that we can do that and it can
be an iterative process of you know if
we we attain some better state of mind
and like life is better and like we're
happy like this happens to people
there's a lot of contentment and peace
and if things are going well and now
something isn't as much go back and look
again right it's it's a process we can
use over and over because it works
because it fits with the truths and the
reality is we as we have understood
learned them you know our education the
you know this will learning about humans
across hundreds of years tells us this
it makes very good sense to me in the
way that you have mapped it out for us
um so much sense in fact that
um I'm just struck by how Divergent it
is from what I think most people think
of when they think of therapy or the
some of the risks of going to a
psychiatrist
um which I think it's only fair to
consider in particular the way that
um at least from my outside non-clinical
understanding
um these sorts of situations of high
levels of demoralization or excessive
aggression or just people not being in
the place or being able to exert their
their
um their actions in the world the way
they want or not get the results they
want is they'll start asking questions
like
um you know maybe I have a chemical
imbalance or or maybe they'll go to a
clinician maybe a cognitive behavioral
therapist or
um or psychiatrist and
more often than not it seems they'll get
you know prescription for X number of
milligrams of some serotonergic Agonist
or uh dopaminergic agonists in it of
course as a neurobiologist I I you know
I applaud the exploration of underlying
brain mechanisms and the involvement of
neuromodulators like dopamine and
serotonin but what you're describing
today is is very different I I think
then
um what most people are can expect if
they go to the typical psychiatrist or
typical psychologist which is part of
the reason we're having this
conversation but um I'd love your
thoughts on that
um and I don't want to make this about
me I only offer this anecdote as a way
to round out a little bit of the earlier
discussion I'll I've never shared this
publicly but when I was a postdoc and
going through that very hard phase of
com competition that I didn't want and
having a hard time staying in touch with
that and there were some other
developmental things starting to
resurface just by virtue of moving back
to the town I grew up in
Etc there I recall getting to the
stairway of the building I was working
in at the time which is the same one
where my laboratory exists now actually
and realizing I couldn't go up the
stairway I've always been reasonably fit
um and just being so exhausted and then
driving home that day on 280 and
thinking you know like none of this
matters like what am I doing like none
of it matters I could have been
exhausted I don't know what it was but
what that ultimately resulted in was me
talking to a psychiatrist who gave me a
low dose of uh of a um of a serotonergic
antidepressant I took that low dose of
serotonergy antidepressant I don't
recall which one it was maybe it was
Citalopram would that make sense and um
spent that evening staring at my plate
of Thai noodles for about two hours it
hit me really hard and and I hated that
feeling and then just stopped taking the
drug
um now I'm not this is no knock on
Citalopram or the use of serotonergic
agents in the proper context they've
saved lives so the problematic too but I
just you know that wasn't the route that
eventually got me out of it it was it
was mainly talk therapy and and
self-care
um but I just offer that because I you
know I even as a neurobiologist i
perhaps especially as a neurobiologist I
thought okay here's the solution right
it's going to shift some internal
modulatory system and I'm going to feel
okay about the situation I'm in and
thank goodness it didn't work even for a
short while because
um the while I didn't do all the things
that you're describing here of exploring
the function of self because no one has
ever laid this out for me I
um I took the route of of talk therapy
which I find immensely beneficial
takes time but immensely beneficial so
what are your thoughts on the current
strategies for diagnosis where those
succeed where they fall short and and
the role of medication in navigating
this you know simple and yet complex
landscape right we are so dramatically
over reductionist you know it's almost
to the point of unbelievable right I
mean think about
getting a medicine getting some say
citalopram
because of what happened right
it can't possibly work
right now maybe a judiciously chosen
medicine could provide a little more
distress tolerance and you could sort of
think about it more and you could find
your way through it but clearly it was
an issue of self right like you're in a
situation that was high stress and are
you going to have to have this
competition or not is it going to be
good for you and you know you don't want
that but can you avoid it like there's
something going on that makes you not be
able to walk up those stairs right so so
again I'm not criticizing I don't want
the person what kind of conversations
you had about it with the person but the
idea that a pill will fix that is like
that's insane right now medicines can
help smooth the way so so let's say you
you initially when the first time you
see someone they say okay we have to
talk about this right what's going on in
your life and you know because normally
you can walk upstairs and go to work
right why can't you now like we need to
think about that we need to talk about
that let's say you start doing that and
you're having a lot of trouble with it
uh or you're just having really high
levels of anxiety we might say look at
medicine can kind of take the
temperature down a little bit you know
give you a little more stress tolerance
and then you know we can you can think
about it better inside of you and we can
talk about it better but it's medicine
in the service of understanding now
sometimes medicines are doing things
like medicines that can help prevent
bipolar episodes right like they're
doing something that is purely
biological but we use so many medicines
for things that are not biological
they're psychological but we we're so
over reductionist that we could actually
over reduce the problem that you said
right like a clear wow that's
fascinating right like how many times
have you gone up those stairs and now
you can't it's so interesting the idea
of like let's just give you a pill I
mean it it really makes no sense but if
we're over reductionist enough you could
see how that's the logical endpoint of
an illogical process right and I'll give
you another example and this is really
it's a true story of uh a woman who
young woman comes into the emergency
room and she says she can't sleep and
you know she looks anxious and she feels
very very anxious uh you know by her
description that's why she can't sleep
and and she gets a sleeping medicine
and she goes home and then she comes
back she comes back a couple days later
and she's very very anxious and she
can't sleep and she looks like she did
before like nothing seems to be
different and she hasn't gotten any
sleep at all so
the doctor in charge gives her a higher
dose of the sleeping medicine
then she goes home
and then she comes back yet again and
nothing is any different she's still not
sleeping she's still anxious and then
the doctor concludes that she's drug
seeking because she wants more and more
of the sleeping medicine
okay
was actually going on was she was
getting hurt at home
she was terrified to go home
of course she couldn't sleep right like
bad things
were happening right but no one asked
the question right they thought she
cannot sleep we'll give sleeping
medicine instead of asking why right and
then she gets home to send home and when
the medicine doesn't work well now
there's something wrong with her
right and you put that label on her now
she's drug seeking right then she's not
going to get any help right so I'm not
against medicines I mean I I use
psychopharmacology as part of my
practice and I think from a from a
biologically based perspective about
many things but we have to know what
something is the answer for and what
something is not the answer for and in
the in the overly reductionist world of
throughput in in Healthcare Systems
people are even being trained these days
that don't know any different right I'm
trying to be overly critical of
practitioners because often
practitioners are working in impossible
situations where the goal is through
throughput and that's more efficient in
the short term right it's more efficient
today right but it's of course not good
in anything but the today term and it's
interesting because it's never good for
the person even today it's like never
good for the people in it right but but
often these decisions are being made
based upon business and money and I
understand business and money I'm I'm a
capitalist I'm interested in these
things but the way that we have let
things get the business and money with
the short-sighted short-term perspective
then bonds with the over reductionist
ways that we approach medicine and then
we have these bizarre things happen and
these kind of bizarre things and lives
right it changed the courses of lives
like fortunately you you know you got
you got what you needed and you figured
things out but if you hadn't would you
have the career you have like we don't
know right or if if someone else hadn't
realized like let's talk to that woman
and see what's going on they'll would
she have survived I mean we don't we
don't know but the point of that is like
lots of bad things
happen right as we're rolling the dice
too many times with too many people and
it doesn't have to be that way and the
way that we're doing it now is not only
inefficient
financially right the thing is that we
seem to be caring about most it leads to
bad outcomes and it also makes no sense
right we're looking at it through this
sort of bizarre lens then we may find
within us the strength to change that
and to change it in a way that actually
fits the science and fits the common
sense
and I have to imagine that both for
people who require medication in order
to cope in order to manage their way
through these questions about function
of self and how they are in the world
what they're paying attention to Etc
and for people who don't require
medication to do this exploration that
this very same exploration is the road
map to feeling yes agency gratitude
peace contentment and Delight medicines
may have a role so if for example we go
look at the pillars and things are not
going so well and and you see that
whenever that person has a bipolar manic
episode while things get really really
damaged and like it's very very hard
they can't recover from that in the ways
they want to then we'd say well let's
we're going to use medicine to help this
right now of course there are other
things to use behavioral changes for
example right but there's but there's a
clear biological role just like we use
medicine to stop seizures right but
people also have to make sure they're
not super sleep deprived there's another
part to it too we can use medicine to
prevent bipolar episodes but there's
another part of self-care involved too
but it's it's a role of medicine right
just as if anxiety levels aren't coming
down too much say for the person to get
at the trauma right they know there's a
trauma they've talked around it you know
for 20 years they know it's been
impacting them they're not sure how it's
hard to go there they're with a trusted
therapist but it's still it's hard to
put words to it and now you know they're
maybe having a panic attack right they
think okay let's we can use medicines to
take the temperature down to sort of
either ease that person's Way Forward so
that they can understand something right
that then provides a resolution in that
part of the pillar and then you know
things are set in a better place so so
the biological aspect you know and
specifically here we're talking about
medicines has its place but the idea
that medicines are a substitute for
understanding
this makes no sense
well you've provided us an incredible
framework thank you
you know this framework really speaks to
all of us right you know that the
components that make us who we are you
know that as you
put it the structure of the self you
know everything from the unconscious
mind conscious mind defense mechanisms
character structure self and the
functions of self
you know these components of
self-awareness defense mechanisms
reaching up from that Iceberg under the
water
what we pay attention to our behaviors
and hopefully our strivings and sense of
hope and how those two pillars flow up
into empowerment humility
agency and gratitude again as action
terms as active terms
and eventually to peace contentment and
Delight in this notion of generative
drive as well as some of the pitfalls
and and
um challenges that can pull down on
generative drive or occlude generative
drive and you very clearly pointed us to
where we should all look
in terms of understanding ourselves
better and where we could do better and
be better in the world
because this is a series we have the
wonderful opportunity to
um have you tell us even more about how
this structure plays out both in terms
of its healthy expression and in terms
of its unhealthy expression you know in
different pathologic conditions that you
know most of us are familiar with at
least in name and and I'm sure you're
going to tell us more about you know
what the what the real
um both underpinnings and expressions of
things like narcissism and you know
extreme and Mild form um you know
anxiety and its extreme and Mild forms
um and and also some of the uh the names
and diagnoses that we're more familiar
with hearing uh about such as you know
bipolar disorder obsessive compulsive
things of that sort
um but that all relate back to and and
really are nested in the this structure
and function of self and where it can
all go so
um first of all I want to say and thank
you really an immense thank you for for
oh you're so welcome for defining the
structure and making it so clear to to
me and to everybody else and and as you
said it it has its complexity there's in
fact immense complexity down there at
the bottom but that
flows up from complex to to very simple
ideals and a road map to get there and
again the PDF is available to people as
a link in the show note captions um
should they want to see this in visual
form I also want to thank you for
assembling the structure not just as a
tutorial but because at least to my
knowledge
no such structure
or summary of these structures it exists
anywhere in the world and certainly not
in any form that the the non-clinician
and not you know highly trained
psychiatrist could ever access or
understand so this is both an immense
resource and an immense gift to us all
thank you so very much you're so welcome
and thank you for having me here which
is a gift
um to be continued in the next episode
thank you
thank you for joining me for this first
episode of our series on Mental Health
with Dr Paul Conte and I encourage you
to keep an eye out for the second
episode in the series which is going to
be about how to improve your mental
health I'll just remind you that all
episodes of The huberman Lab podcast can
be accessed completely zero cost and in
all formats by going to hubermanlab.com
if you're learning from and or enjoying
this podcast please subscribe to our
YouTube channel that's a terrific zero
cost way to support us in addition
please subscribe to the podcast on both
Spotify and apple and on both Spotify
and apple you can leave us up to a
five-star review please also check out
the sponsors mentioned at the beginning
and throughout today's episode that's
the best way to support this podcast if
you have questions for me or comments
about the podcast or guess that you'd
like me to consider hosting on the
huberman Lab podcast please put those in
the comments section on YouTube I do
read all the comments and if you're not
already following me on social media I
am hubermanlab on all platforms so
that's Instagram Twitter LinkedIn
threads and Facebook and on all those
platforms I discuss signs science
related tools some of which overlap with
the content of the uberman Lab podcast
but much of which is distinct from the
content of the huberman Lab podcast so
again it's huberman lab on all social
media channels not on today's episode
but on many previous episodes of The
huberman Lab podcast we discuss
supplements while supplements aren't
necessary for everybody many people
derive tremendous benefit from them for
things like enhancing sleep for hormone
support and for Focus if you'd like to
see the supplements discussed on the
Hebrew Lab podcast you can go to live
momentous spelled ous so it's
livemomentis.com huberman if you haven't
already subscribed to our newsletter it
is a zero cost newsletter called the
neural network newsletter and in the
neural network newsletter you get free
podcast summaries as well as tool kits
the toolkits are brief PDFs that list
off the specific science-backed
protocols for things like improving your
sleep improving Focus optimizing
dopamine deliberate cold exposure we
have a complete summary of our fitness
series again all available completely
zero cost you simply go to
hubermanlab.com go to the menu scroll
down to newsletter and provide your
email to sign up we do not share your
email with anybody thank you once again
for joining me for today's discussion
which is the first episode in our series
about mental health with Dr Paul Conte
and last but certainly not least thank
you for your interest in science
[Music]